there's no time
13 o clock all right everybody it's
Tuesday and it's New Year's Day happy
2019 everybody yeah first it's not New
Year's Day today but we're gonna see
this all you're gonna see it on New
Year's Day see I was trying to be all
slick yeah but you ruined pre-recording
I'll tell you what that new book is
selling the audiobook is selling fast
yeah in case you guys didn't see our
last movie retrospective which was
soldier I happen to mention on there
finally finally audible has put my book
faceless villain month volume to the
audiobook version they put it up for
sale on Christmas Day notice but it has
actually sold quite a few copies the
first two days it was up and I was like
actually very yeah between 10 and 15
copies a day yeah retro actively selling
part one yeah so I'm kind of hoping
because we saw that audible you know I
was saying well it's probably because
it's new and they probably put it in
their featured you know new crime
section yeah so I feel like that's
probably the case which is that's fine
with me you know yeah and so like I said
you know I should probably be getting
codes cuz they usually send you the
codes for the free ones and I'll
probably send them to our patrons first
but if I have any left over I will let
you know when I get those and yeah well
seventy if you have an audible account
or Amazon current Amazon account so you
can leave actually it really does help
like having reviews on there I've
noticed that my books that only have
like one or two reviews now so you know
they don't sell as much but if you get
up in the thing of having like 5 6 7 8 9
10 reviews then people start because you
know nobody wants to buy something that
they not reviewed right know anything
about you know that's just the way it
works so if anyone
has bought it you guys bought it and you
liked it then please leave a review yeah
I'm building genius soundbooth yeah with
all the sound yeah for Christmas I got a
little shelf that we can install in
there that I can put my laptop and the
microphone on oh I can actually stand up
in the booth it's gonna rerecord all the
old stuff yeah so it's all gonna go up
in new revised editions and I'm doing my
fiction - I think I'm a boy that's never
been an audiobook I just never gonna be
a different reading of unseen hand it's
gonna sound more kind of like Jenny's
normal show delivery of that one's gonna
be good except without the swearing yeah
it's hard for me to talk without
swearing right
maybe another edition of math Mountain
yeah I think we talked before about how
we're gonna I want to expand that book
and make it longer and because there was
some more stuff that we could have added
you know and when I did the audio book
you know I added stuff that wasn't in
the print version our equipment wasn't
very good more stuff has happened with
the case that book could be updated yeah
second edition I think a second edition
deluxe man fountain was probably pretty
cool its deluxe it's like right Irian
collection we'll put the real names for
certain locations and certain people in
there yeah we're not putting on the name
of the place because I'm you know it's
not like the books you know it's not
like millions of people are reading it
and they'll all like turn up at this
place or anything like that but I don't
know I like to keep my ass covered right
yeah the place where that happened is
for sale
yeah it's always for sale it's kind of
creepy because we looked it up what was
it on Zillow or something like that and
we saw yeah it's always up for sale and
I wonder why we did a show about that
yeah show them where it where it was and
everything yeah because we don't picture
zuv it on a real estate site yeah of
what it looks like now I mean it's
changed a little bit since he stayed
there but he's still recognized like
delay
and everything like that so yeah it was
kind of creepy you want to move into a
vacation condo and yeah California okay
anymore based on you know based on you
know what we believe it's about you know
no it's not there anymore
well no cuz it followed your ass here
yeah let's do and [ __ ] here like ringing
our doorbell back sir I bet you that
[ __ ] you kick up again it probably
would we've thought about doing that
thought about when I read it out for a
week if we could afford it like we could
go out there and stay in it for a week
and see if anything happened I bet it
would because you'd probably be all
creeped out start that damn would you
start it up again yeah I'm pretty sure
yeah because you got kind of creeped out
just looking at the pictures and it
looks kind of different now than it did
then but yeah you know I get creeped out
sometimes weird [ __ ] like CD drawer
start opening up yeah that does
definitely happens because he has to be
doorbell starts ringing yeah he has to
be like in the right frame of mind but
when he's in the right frame of mind
okay doorbell start swearing and draw
grudge door starts over yeah things
vanish never reappear speaking of
paranormal just on Thursday night of
this past week I was on live radio it's
boring the bizarre on cake or radio I
was on there with Keith Linder yeah we
were talking about the Seattle demon
house which I wrote a book about and
also he's written a book about it
because I kind of wrote about Steve
Myers experiences and Keith's word about
his experiences so there's two books out
about it so I'll let you guys know when
they archive it they also do a YouTube
version but that usually takes a couple
weeks so I'll put a link in the sidebar
when it comes out so if you didn't catch
it wife you should be able to catch it
later on it was a pretty interesting
show Keith's actually a really nice guy
I think this is the first share that I
actually did with Keith yeah I've done a
bunch with Steve but I think this is the
first one I do with Keith it was really
you know it was really I've talked with
Keith you know dear when we were right
in his book yeah I had like extensive
conversations with him you know that you
know nobody else knows about just you
yeah he's an interesting guy he really
is it's a weird case it's very weird
yeah but yeah so we talked about that a
little bit so like I said I'll put lane
when the archived version comes up let's
see what else our last movie
retrospective as I said with soldier the
crustle film yeah something went on
their table I would have dumped a
dumpster fire that is man I said take
that take that [ __ ] off there no one
cares about your stupid opinions yeah
lucky I don't block you that's like I
don't like like I said you know if
something sucks I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna blow smoke up its ass and say that
it's good but it's like I'm not gonna
dwell on it either yeah it's like if you
don't like it go find something you do
like I don't everybody's gonna
everybody's got taste it's like music
yeah I guess who they just love certain
music right but it's like I'm not gonna
get a jump on him about it it's like I
used to know this guy who was like a big
movie buff which I am too and he and you
know he had a lot of same tastes as me
but if you didn't like a movie that he
did like he would [ __ ] argue with you
about it like why you should have liked
it yeah and I'm like son that's not how
it works it's subjectivity hook it up
sometime yeah um but like I said if
people like something that I hate that
I'm not gonna get all up in their [ __ ]
about it's not my business
yeah it's like you know when last Jedi
came out I hated it a lot of guys
couldn't stand it but I really can't
relate to these guys where they have
whole channels based around why that
movie suck they're still stuck on it why
that movies I know they are that is the
saddest thing yeah yeah so sad just get
a fine [ __ ] you do like there's so much
stuff in the world please stop wasting
your time on [ __ ] that you don't
understand I would like watching those
shows you know for like a couple of
weeks you know coming he's coming in it
with new angles of why it sucked but
it's been over a year now
you know you imagine being inside the
head of someone that's like all that is
just like [ __ ] think about [ __ ] to
whine about that why Star Wars sucks I
can't imagine it I can't war sucks
because the people who make Star Wars
now are not the same people who used to
make Star Wars at stage that's what
happens people get old people die
gonna do and honestly like I said I know
people piss and moan about this and that
but it's like you know we've been going
since we've had our a list you know our
a MCA list thing I mean we've seen like
quite a lot of good movies we've seen a
couple kind of shitty ones but not many
I was like sick I I was kind of thinking
maybe we'll whole like Watson blue well
everybody's yeah that blue half of it
was funny but then it just went down
yeah I'm not a big fan of Will Ferrell
anyway i love john c reilly especially
in his dramatic roles he's actually a
better dramatic actor but he's a good
comedic actor too
you know like i said some of the jokes
were like obvious but you know it's it's
stupid humor it's just same kind of
stuff as stepbrothers yeah you know a
lot of the movies I think have gotten a
little bit better
recently honestly this week you know and
you guys have will have seen it if you
watch matinee on Sunday I loved the
favorite favorite was good oh my god
Aquaman was good I loved the favorite so
much you guys it's like I'm gonna buy
that [ __ ] and actually the when we saw
it I loved it and the more I thought
about it like in the ensuing days the
more I liked it alright now it gets all
the Oscars Aquaman was really good I
actually really liked oh yeah it was
super fun on undersea Flash Gordon
really like I said it's like and I think
I said it's in the review it was like it
was cheesy as [ __ ] but like it owned it
yeah it was like yeah it's [ __ ]
cheesy that's right yeah it was that's
why me it was super fun it don't take
itself too seriously prized that into
the spider-verse was pretty good that
was actually amazing based on how much
the comic books suck now for the model
like the spider-man comic books suck
right now although a lot of people like
that Miles Morales character which is
why they made a whole movie based around
it well I don't think a comic book for
my Miles Morales is any good though
either heard the writing is pretty bad
but the the cotton well I don't movie
was good I can't speak to that because I
kept hearing that the writing was pretty
bad but um thing is is that it's just
like Peter Parker it's the same kind of
the same character he can vanish yeah he
can turn invisible I really kind of like
Spider Man O'War better out of them
we'd like to see that like the CT you
know I heard the baby when I heard that
they are doing a spin-off of spider twin
what about spider Noir I'm not sure but
um I think that's gonna be the next one
in that that offshoot I think they're
doing one about spider Gwen's Daisy yeah
but yeah I'd like to see no is that I
watch a whole movie about spider-ham as
well because that ship is a little pig
that looks like spider-man yes okay so
what ax murders ax murders okay so
that's a also I wanted to say um I
always do thank yous our newest patron
is named it's either via or via I'm not
sure so I just I'm covering the bases
for both pronunciations right yeah
that's what I'm thinking so thank you
very much also our previous patron
Sophie has also increased her support by
quite a large amount so thank you very
much you too yeah I'm Sophie very much
appreciated especially over the
Christmas season like I said cuz I know
everyone's broke I know money on
Christmas presents a ham and [ __ ] we got
a good Christmas present yeah he got me
so much cool [ __ ] dude he got me The
Criterion Collection blu-ray of Twin
Peaks fire walk with me you guys know
how much I love David Lynch clothes and
you got me a [ __ ] ton of really nice
clothes yeah I got new running shoes
because the Kitty stole one of my
running shoes and we never found we
closer guys took that put it into
something that I threw it got thrown
away that's possible maybe she put it
into a box and I threw the Box away the
Box got thrown out that's possible I
don't know but it's the cat is obviously
smarter than we are because she hid it
in some place where we never discovered
it gone I'm starting to think that it
got thrown away it probably did cuz it's
nowhere it is nowhere yes [ __ ] house
alright so this is the first show of
2019 and I thought what better way to
start off the new year then with some
[ __ ] axe murders you know much I love
axe Mirai don't love axe murders I'm
just fascinated by axe murders for some
reason and we've done a bunch of shows
about axe murders we did hinter Chi FAC
we did the st. Aubyn Street massacre we
did the very famous the
Eliska axe murders of Iowa and also like
I said a lot of people there was a lot
of [ __ ] axe murders in the early 20th
century America I mean a staggering
adventures well there were a lot of axes
land Romaniacs murders really lots of
axes laying around people chill
everybody had one because you know you
needed to cut wood for you know for fire
and and people knew how to use them
right so everybody had one so it was a
weapon of convenience but still that's
still like a weirdly specific thing that
seems like a Midwestern American
phenomenon from the early 20th century
not not just Midwestern because it
wasn't the south and stuff too but where
somebody would just bust into your house
take your axe and chop up your whole
family like well more I think about it
the morgue just kind of sounds like it
might be you know just regular home
invasion
now today nowadays you might have three
or four guys busted your house with
pistols or maybe some shotguns or
something probably to steal your drugs
or your drug money that's usually with a
lot of home invasions are in the drug
war so you know but if you have a
traveler you know guy who's basically a
bum he's on foot he gets desperate he's
got he's tired of sleeping on the road
you know a lot of this is before
automobiles
he says screw it he goes out in the
backyard and finds the woodpile and
there's the axe and he's got a weapon
right there kicks in the door just acts
as the family but you know back in those
days that was very risky because
everybody had guns that's what I mean it
just seems like that's fast I guess
seems to me that this is not I mean
obviously this is not a normal thing for
people to be doing I mean because you
know I would rather sleep under a breath
I'm gonna axe a whole family clean
babies and [ __ ] like that what the [ __ ]
that is [ __ ] up and honestly killing
people with an axe yeah one it's hard
because as we will say we're talking
about the axe man of New Orleans like
half of his victims lived even though
they got axed in the [ __ ] head yeah
you know what I mean so you talking
about 1800s and 1900s and Locke who
don't realize that the United States
didn't really have what you would
consider to be professional police
departments until the 20th century there
were places in the United States did
police departments you know well yeah
30s right you know maybe 20s so you
might have any like a town marshal yeah
well yeah well it's not here anymore so
can do and those you know sheriff's and
marshals and the little neighborhood
police stations I mean they were maybe
like on par with a rent-a-cop you know
or the or security guards that guard the
front of gated communities they didn't
really have that many didn't have much
in the way of investigative techniques
and they couldn't catch the guy and he
skipped town they were never gonna catch
him well yeah they didn't have real
police because like I said and we talked
about this on our Villisca ax murderer
show you know not only I mean Villisca
is the most famous but there were a [ __ ]
ton of other like entire families
getting wiped out with an axe type
situation that happened in Kansas happen
in Colorado Springs like right around
the same time and some people have
speculated that the you know it might be
the same person and the same kind of
thing with ax man of New Orleans this
[ __ ] happened and then the second case
we're gonna talk about which I had never
heard of and this is [ __ ] crazy
this is just like remember the show we
did about the Atlanta Ripper and I said
is into true crime as I am and I love
reading about that kind of [ __ ] I had
never heard of the Atlanta Ripper
I discovered it accidentally while I was
researching another case for my book and
this is another thing the mulatto acts
murders which happened in the early
1900s in Louisiana and Texas I had never
heard of these until someone like a
listener recommended it and I looked it
up and it is even worse than the Axman
of New Orleans and no one ever talks
about it and it's like I could hardly
find it even like I found some old
newspaper somebody had kind of done like
a chronological thing of all the
newspaper reports from the time but
because again just like Atlanta Ripper
because most of the victims were black
or mixed-race it seemed like no one gave
much of a [ __ ] um also there's kind of
and and I'm feel kind of bad that I
didn't really put this in my book but
they think that it might be solved
because someone confessed
but they're not sure if this person was
the only perpetrator or if they got
railroaded or if they just made it up or
they're not really sure so they were
convicted but it was pretty much just
the confession and like that was so what
cases are we taking care of it we're
doing activate in New Orleans and we're
doing the so called mulatto ax murders
also known as the Voodoo murders or I
think that I've also seen them called
the Southern Pacific murders because it
happened along the Southern Pacific
Railway line that kind of simple we'll
talk about that second because that's
kind of a big copley and like I said I'd
never heard of it and I was like reading
it going oh my god this is amazing I
never hear about this [ __ ] it's crazy
it's crazy all right so let's talk about
the accident of New Orleans probably
most people familiar with it if you're
not a big true crime aficionado which
you know if you are you've heard of this
case cuz it's very very famous but if
you haven't if you've seen American
Horror Story season 3 which is called
coven they had a character called the ax
man who was based on this uncaught
serial killer this happened about May
1918 to about October 1919 six people
killed six people wounded there you know
there were a lot of attacks where the
people didn't die I said 19 18 or 18 18
19 18 19 18 19 19 okay I should mention
20th century yeah I should mention too
and some people have requested this and
I want to do a show about this too but
there was also a series of ax murders
back in Dec believe 18 late 1800s like
1880 1890 called the servant girl
Annihilator miners yeah which I love
that [ __ ] name I know it's terrible
but that's like the best [ __ ] name so
I'm gonna have to do something on that
too but like I said there was a lot of
[ __ ] axe murders going on and I don't
know if it was just because the just
because axes were around I don't know
it's just it just seems like such a
theory was because well here's the thing
though I'm every house had I'm pretty
right but people had guns too yeah and
it seems like killing some more than axe
is difficult and messy and it seems like
you would bigoted I mean it seems like
you would get caught really easily
because you'd be covered with gore but
obvi
these people didn't get caught so I
guess it wasn't that I guess what the
situation was I mean if it was a home
invasion it was gonna be you know a
crime of opportunity they know the
person was either asleep or you know
yeah they're for it that the house doors
you know a lot of places especially in
the semi rural areas people didn't lock
their doors yeah and they were wooden
houses so when you walk through the
floor there was no way to sneak up on
anybody yeah
so if you were fast you could probably
just run in yeah ax someone before they
could arm themselves yeah cuz people had
guns all people had guns even in cities
back in the nice day well yeah first
they did it in the early 20th century
there was no concept of anything like
gun control I mean why would you want
that you just wouldn't there were no
police you had to protect yourself you
know I think so particularly in rural
area but in the cities to still to this
day you know you have like people live
in cities in the United States you know
they're yeah they're gun control
advocates you couldn't where I came from
in Mississippi you couldn't have gun
control there cuz you can't call the
cops you call the cops it might be 40
minutes before the show up yeah cuz it's
so far and and you know a town might
only have two policemen one for the day
one for the night you're gonna you're
gonna entrust your Santina to and they
don't give a [ __ ] about you well they're
probably not I mean they're like those
guys yeah you know because everyone
lives so far a bit in these rural areas
that know what it's like not a lot of
crime happens doesn't really it doesn't
happen that much because you know your
neighbors you know the names of your
neighbors
everybody's watching everybody else's
[ __ ] yeah and races in the factor my dad
still lives in that environment and his
neighbors are all black country people
and they watch out for him they called
they called the ambulance when he's
starting to go down with the heart
attack they're visiting him you know I
mean it's not this stereotypical [ __ ]
you see in a Hollywood movies you know
and that in Mississippi today everybody
gets along pretty much yeah best day out
in the country so to people country
public will survive alright so the first
thing let's talk about the very famous
ax man of New Orleans
now this person or persons was a serial
killer like I said ultimate victim tally
as far as they know it was six also six
wounded normally what this killer would
do was they would take a chisel and they
would like bust out like a panel on a
door to break in they would always break
in while the people were sleeping so
through the middle of the night they
would usually ax them in the head but
usually with the blunt side because you
don't want to use the sharp side because
it'll get stuck and blah-dee-blah
it does it doesn't have knockdown power
right what force trama is very effective
yeah they do that yeah generally nothing
was ever stolen from the house almost
always the perpetrator would use the
people's own axe sometimes a straight
razor and so it was always like a weapon
of convenience and mostly they would
leave the weapons behind at the scene
they were only seen a couple of times
and very very fleetingly
so there's pretty much no description of
this person and they're not they still
to this day have no idea and nothing
taking me nope never it's a thrill kill
yeah it does seem to be exactly that and
like the Zodiac this person also well
allegedly this person sent a letter to
the newspaper you know at some point
during the reign of terror whether this
was actually the killer or not I don't
know but it is a very famous letter and
I'll tell you you know I'll give you a
little summary of it later on now most
of the victims of the Axman of New
Orleans were Italians or Italian Italian
immigrants Italian Americans and a lot
of them were grocers weirdly so they're
not sure if it was ethnically motivated
some people have speculated maybe it was
mafia related but that doesn't seem my
mafia doesn't usually go around axing
people it's like too messy like I said
they usually just pop you in the head
but you know some people have speculated
that maybe it was like a you know a
sexual crime or sexual type of thrill
even though both men and women were
killed you know I've seen some crime
writers say oh well they only killed the
men when
and you know they were in the way of the
women getting killed but one of the
crimes was an old man that got killed
and there were two girls in the house
who were his nieces who weren't killed
or were even weren't even attacked so I
don't I don't know how much you know I
want to give to that because it doesn't
really seem but so what the motive for
this is who [ __ ] knows now if they're
connected they're sure they were
connected see that's another thing it's
like some people thought even though the
mo in pretty much every case was very
very very similar some have speculated
that perhaps only a couple of them were
related and then the others were
copycats which could have been but like
I said the mo was just so so similar
with a you know sometimes what would
happen as a sensational case would
happen in pretty much every detail the
case would be printed out in the local
newspaper yeah that sounds like a good
idea the locals would say that oh man
wow that's quite a you know an
incredible crime you know I owe this
grocer over here a bunch of money I
don't like that guy he's an [ __ ]
[ __ ] kill him make it look like that
other one they'll blame that kid it's a
win-win yeah so copycatting isn't always
what you think it is yeah well yeah
because like I said I would have an
enemy and then blame it on somebody yeah
and actually they said that in some of
the Atlanta Ripper murders too that's
not that's why they're not entirely sure
how many people this Atlanta Ripper
actually killed because they speculated
that some people that lived in the
neighborhood might he said hey I can get
rid of my girlfriend yeah and blame it
on this serial killer so and they just
kill them in that way what happens it
can become kind of like a pandemic of it
right exactly where you know it's like I
kill for it's a kill for all long as you
make the homicide look like this you'll
be scot-free yeah yeah yeah I can see
that happening yeah people aren't what
they are made out to be yeah we put
[ __ ] a lot of some sometimes then
it's [ __ ] get knocked off though -
you can't you don't know is it
it's true situation I do kind of felt
like I have some days I try not to be so
cynical I know I'm getting all that I'm
getting more cynical in my old age well
I don't know I don't know if that's true
because I was cynical when I was a
teenager too but I always kind of feel
like you know you only hear about the
[ __ ] because they're [ __ ] and I
mean it's kind of like a big deal and
you hear about them they make more noise
they make more but I feel like most of
the time probably 80% of people all
right well probably 80% of people are
alright yeah although it all just
depends you know like a lot of the crime
statistics you see here in the United
States if you actually get down to the
nitty gritty it's one bad guy killing
another bad guy over money that's most
of it
it doesn't seem like that's a lot of as
long as you're not in the drug trade
your chances of being murdered or
[ __ ] very small although like I said
since I write about true crime there are
too many cases of just people hey random
yeah I was just walking down the street
yeah got off the bus and was walking
home from working well the sudden any
amount of those seems like too much yeah
any amount of those is too much and but
if you actually do the statistics you're
probably more likely to be struck by
lightning or killed by bees or much more
likely to be killed in a car accident
well see that's what I try to think
there's like like I said you know I
write about this [ __ ] all day long but
I'm also a very statistics minded person
so I'm just like yes this is horrifying
yes it would suck if it happened to you
it would suck for your family obviously
but the chances of it happening are
infinitesimally small and probably you
should worry more about wearing your
seat belt and you're crossing the street
and yeah when you like it's telling you
look at the firearm when you look at
firearms related violence is what's
called in the United States the number
looks big but in that number they also
have all the suicides and they also have
all the police shootings in there you
take those out then you deal with a
pretty big chunk and if you look at that
chunk most that's drug trade related
yeah it is so yeah I mean most of the
time you have guys here but then it
freaks out a lot of foreigners and you
see [ __ ] on holiday on Hollywood movies
you think that you can just ride around
you're gonna randomly get shot that's
very rare here
very very rare depending on what
neighborhood yeah it might happen in a
very drug-infested neighborhood where
there's drug wars yeah but you know you
can pray you know the night every major
city kind of has a little area like that
yeah I mean I don't usually feel all
that unsafe no sometimes I do like if
I'm downtown obviously you know and
people are drunk and [ __ ] like that I'm
more worried about that kind of [ __ ]
where people are like walking around
they're drunk and yeah doing some stupid
[ __ ] I worry more about that yeah we do
go downtown a lot that but where we live
I don't want pulse nightclub shooting
happen in just a mile up for more
distinctly woke up we were out that
night yeah what's the hair right down
the street we also had a guy shoot at
the shoot at one of our favorite
bouncers yeah threw him out and he 22
with 22 pistol shot at the door and the
police station was right there yeah he's
got it the police station is right
around the corner from our favorite
haunt our favorite nightclub it's like
it's literally right there it's right
there there's like there's like the
nightclub there's another nightclub yeah
pizza place you know where he was and
there's the police station jackass
didn't know where he was I guess not got
drunk got thrown out and he went got his
picture wasn't thinking of yeah you guys
pissed a lot of shrunken I'm going back
into that Club [ __ ] shut the door on
him and he shot at the door and the cops
are right there yeah like I said we were
downtown the night of the pulse shooting
but and we were just down the street but
we didn't hear about it until the next
day right you know what I mean
it was like if so it's creepy to think
about but you know weird [ __ ] happens
here it does yeah I mean it's Florida
yeah there's a there's a meme about
Florida man for a reason all right so
let's talk about the victims of the axe
man of New Orleans now the first ones
were Italian grocers Joseph Maggio and
his wife Katherine now they had a
grocery store in New Orleans and they
lived on the premises also like many
business people did back in the day
evidently same as this is pretty much
the killer's mo he used a chisel to get
into their back door he actually cut
their throats first
with a straight razor and then before he
left like hit them both in the head
almost as though he wanted to cover up
the attack although Cather Maggio I mean
the the throat cutting was so severe
that she was almost decapitated hmm
now Joseph Maggio was actually still
alive after the killer left his brothers
who lived next door actually discovered
him one of his brothers had heard him
groaning through the wall and they came
over and found them now this was about
two hours after the attack but by the
time the brothers got there and found
them then Joseph had passed away as well
so that's the thing that and so again
they find the they find bloody clothes
in the house which apparently the
murderer has taken off so he's changed
into another outfit they also found the
axe that had been used they found it in
the backyard
of another property and they don't
change clothes did he change into the
into their clothes oh I don't know or
did he bring some see yeah I would try
to see if any of their clothes were
missing yeah I've never seen that said
anywhere they just said that they found
some bloody clothes as if he had changed
clothes but maybe he brought a change of
clothes because he knew how messy acts
and this and that's awful risky to leave
behind your blood-stained clothes at a
murder scene whoever this was they never
got caught but they didn't seem like
they were all that worried about maybe
he wasn't wearing his clothes maybe not
maybe he was wearing a clothes or
somebody he didn't like a person got the
blood on those clothes and then changed
into their clothes leaving his enemies
close behind blood-stained
I mean like I said again this was 1918
and maybe even criminals back then knew
the police ain't [ __ ] yeah they can't do
anything yeah unless they [ __ ] see you
doing it right so maybe they weren't all
that worried about it because I didn't
have DNA yeah and he doesn't know what
the [ __ ] that was back maybe if nobody
in that town knew who you were because
you were just passing through there's no
chance that they could identify your
clothing that's what the thinking was I
kind of feel like a lot of these axe
murders and I think I said this on the
Villisca one too because I feel
a lot of these were drifters or somebody
that was just going in and out of town
particularly on the on the railway
because back then I mean it was like
super easy to just jump on a train and
just halo to the next town and acts a
whole family yeah hobos is beyond those
trains yeah you could go like all over
the country and no one would for free
right and no one would like me the wiser
so I feel like that might have been
what's going on here although this
person did kill a lot of people in the
New Orleans area over this brief period
time is about a year and a half and ever
since you ever fish is doing that to
member yeah
we're gonna have to do a show about that
motherfucker's yeah means jumping up on
those trains and raping dudes and that's
something isn't it weird yeah I think it
was out from fish before I settle down I
don't remember I think you think he was
a bum for awhile a hobo
and would ride around those trains
unless I'm confusing to someone else
before in and then he eventually he
settled down into being a painter I
could have swore if I remember correctly
he started he started it as a hobo
working those trains yeah I don't think
it was him I don't know he liked raping
other guys yeah it was before he got
into kids I think think of the same guy
that seems a little weird that seems
weird though that you'd start out with
one thing like that and then kind of oh
I'm gonna be a pedophile I decided you
know I think you from what I remember he
started off as a teenager on those
trains that could be like I said I'm
gonna have to do more research about
that yeah a lot of what ever questioned
us to Albert yeah he's so disgusting I
mean not like we haven't done disgusting
[ __ ] I don't mind it he was a state of
masochist that dude yeah so here's the
thing though they find out like the
straight razor that has been used to
kill the Maggio's actually belonged to
the victim's brother who was a barber
however the person that one of the
people that worked in the in the barber
shop that the brother that the brother
ran said oh yeah well he sent that razor
out too you know whatever the razor
fixing place was back then like to get a
nick honed out of the blade so for a
while they were suspecting the brother I
don't know if they suspected anybody
that worked at the race
fixing place because you'd think they'd
be like hey I could use this razor so
he's trying to frame people yeah it
could be
doctor why would you leave close behind
yeah he was trying to frame people with
those clothes that's actually something
I've never seen mentioned I wonder if
that's the case yeah because the brother
was because they asked him they're like
okay well they were getting murdered
like two hours ago and you were home
why didn't you hear that [ __ ] because
you know the murderer broke into the
house it's like chiseled out the door
panel and [ __ ] and you were right next
door and the brother was like oh well
I'm joining the Navy and I was out at a
party and I got super inebriated and so
he's like so I was home and I was like
drunk sleeping good so you know which
that's you know that's totally legit
somebody didn't knew him but they you
know they couldn't find anything about
it so they initially they had to let him
go
and and so now the next attack happened
this was on June 27 1918 this was
another grocer named Lewis bezu May and
he lived behind his store with his
mistress
Harriet lo he had a wife but she lived
somewhere else right [ __ ] like that
would have yeah there was this whole
thing this one was like okay so this
happens they both got hit in the head
with an axe at the blunt side of the axe
covered with blood they were discovered
by the bread delivery guy the next
morning now they both lived they were
unconscious when they got there and
didn't remember anything but they both
ultimately survived although Harriet
load died later now the weird thing
about this the first thing that cops did
was they arrested a dude that Lewis Beza
may had just hired he was a black man
and his name was Louis Rubicon he was
about 41 years old he said oh well
obviously this guy is black and he just
started working here and they just got
hit with an axe so it must be him it's
gotta be him so that was pretty much all
the good thinking of the time yeah so
you know he was he was working while
black yeah we're collapsing
Seppo working for the white people while
black I guess
well yes so they decided okay well
obviously it's this guy but obviously
they couldn't find any evidence against
this poor guy and then they let him out
now here's the crazy thing though
Harriette lo um she I hate to cast
aspersions on this woman because she did
die later from the from complications
from her injuries but she seemed kind of
crazy because as soon as they I mean
they took her to the hospital for
injuries and everything like that now
initially she said oh it was a mulatto
man that attacked me and I realized
that's kind of an offensive term I did
use it for him a lot of axe murders
because that's usually what they're
known as but that's only offensive today
back in those days yeah back in those
days it wasn't offensive but so that's
what she said at first but then she said
and the police didn't really believe her
because she seemed kind of histrionic
and honestly the more she was in the
hospital and she started when it came
out in the media that she was Louie Beza
Mae's mistress rather than his wife Shh
you know there was all kind of [ __ ] in
the media about her and then she started
accusing the media of oh you just said
that to discredit me and she started
[ __ ] on the chief of police and
saying I'm not gonna cooperate with this
investigation blah-dee-blah
and then she comes out and says no it
was Lois bezu may her boyfriend who was
also attacked no it was him that did it
so they searched his [ __ ] and they find
this trunk and it's got these letters in
it that are written in various languages
German Yiddish Russian what-have-you so
they conclude he's a German spy and then
Harriet lo helpfully says yes he is a
German spy so they arrested the dude
further murder right so so he gets let
out of jail like only a couple days
later the two police officers that
arrest him or like demoted and all this
other kind of [ __ ] now meanwhile Harriet
lo she's in the hospital this whole time
like making up all these crazy stories
they
did surgery on her face because you know
the attack had actually paralyzed half
of her face so they did surgery and they
were trying to fix it but there were
complications from the surgery and she
actually ended up dying hmm
now Louie bez may was put was arrested
again like later on you know for being a
spy for being a murder whatever they
actually did put him on trial but after
10 minutes the jury acquitted him
because they were just like this
trumpets you know this was the craziest
[ __ ] ever you know so there was that
whole thing so there was yeah there was
a whole media circus about that now they
couldn't remember anything after the
attack they were leap when they attack
yes okay in every single case the
victims were asleep it was Casper he was
Casper in people yes Casper the Friendly
Ghost is when you sneak up on somebody
when they're asleep and kill not so
friendly Casper yeah I like that
I never heard that term but I like that
as a I like that used as a verb you've
been Casper yeah oh all right so the
next attack this is a poor 28 year old
woman named Anna Schnieder she was eight
months pregnant now she had a husband
but I don't think he was home at the
time she woke up in the middle of the
night saw a dark figure hovering over
her her who then just bashed her in the
face with a blunt object which she could
not recognize at the time um and she was
knocked unconscious now her husband came
home from work and found her in that
state and took her to the hospital
now she did eventually recover two days
later she actually gave birth to a
healthy baby girl so you know I know
she's badass
she kept [ __ ] bashed in the face with
a [ __ ] man gave birth yeah and then
she's like you know suck it right I was
I hit him with the flat edge right in
the face huh this actually was not an
axe they weren't sure they thought the
weapon might have been there was like a
big heavy lamp that had been on a table
like next and they think that he bashed
her in the face with that cuz like I
said it seems like he would just he
didn't bring anything to the scene he
would just kind of come in and go do
they have an axe do they have
straight razor oh well all they have is
a lamp so I guess I'll just use that so
he just bashed her in the face with that
and like I said no no rape no robbery no
nothing he just come he just breaks in
the house bashes everyone in the head
and leaves he's getting off on the the
power the choosing who's gonna die and
the power you wield from being invisible
invisibly terrorizing the community
holding them and in the clutches of fear
now if the letter and I'm gonna get to
that they're gonna know when I strike
that kind yeah and I know there is this
bag me I'll probably read the whole
probably find it amazing if indeed this
let this famous letter was written by
the same person that was doing the
murders then I think was his attitude
like I just said yeah that's probably
the same guy so at this stage this
seemed like the person had not had to
break in they had just come in through
like an open window and had like I said
bash the woman's face in with a lamp
initially they arrested this dude named
James Gleeson who they said was an
ex-convict
but they you know and really he just ran
away from the police because he was like
[ __ ] the police I don't want to get
arrested he didn't know what he did or
anything like that they couldn't find
any evidence so they eventually had to
let him go now the next attack occurred
on August 10th 1918 now this was an
older man he was in his 70s his name was
Joseph Romano and he lived in a house
with his two young nieces their names
were at Pauline and Mary Bruno and they
were actually in another room when this
happened they woke up in the middle of
the night heard a commotion coming from
their uncle's room and went in there to
see a person fleeing from their room and
their uncle's head and face was all
covered in blood and [ __ ] up now they
said that this person had dark skin was
heavyset and was wearing a black suit
and a black slouch hat that's what they
said good so Joseph Romano was not
killed outright in fact when the
ambulance came to the house he was able
to walk to the ambulance however he died
two days later from his injuries yeah so
I had promised
affection I mean what was it this was
1989 yeah and penicillin then did they I
don't think they did today yeah I think
that might have been a few years later
yeah if you got sick back then you were
[ __ ] he got infected you were a goner
yeah pretty much so I feel like like
after this particular attack I mean yes
there had been ones before this and it
had been horrible but this one was kind
of the one that sort of lit the spark of
panic like in the city because people
like oh [ __ ] there's this phantom he's
just breaking into people's houses and
axing them to death and you know so
there was like a whole panic thing going
on and then you know all these
detectives come out and said said [ __ ]
like oh it's a Jekyll and Hyde character
he's probably just a normal person and
maybe it's someone you know and then
like at night they just turn into this
crazy monster type of person now the
next attack yeah well the next attack
happened on March 10th 1919 this was
Charles Court Amelia also an Italian
immigrant he had a wife named Rosie and
they had a little girl a little toddler
named Mary and they so the same thing
happened someone breaks in their house
and attacks them now
their neighbor who was across the street
was another Italian grocer named Orlando
Giordano and he heard screaming coming
with house so he ran over there to help
them now he sees that Charles Court
Emilia is laying on the floor his head
is covered in blood
rosy court Emilia is standing in the
doorway with her dead baby Dan her
[ __ ] arms kill the baby yeah he tried
to kill them to bash the baby yeah damn
so did you see him here's the thing this
again this is like really making it hard
to make me feel bad for you guys because
so Charles and Rosie lived their
daughter died sadly hmm however
afterwards
Rosie court amelia said oh you know who
attacked us it was your land Oh Giordano
and his son Frank who were their
neighbors who lived who came to help
them when they were screaming really and
they're like one she said there were two
of them yeah okay one you're Elena
Giordano yeah
was old right and in very poor health
there like there's just maybe sure her
brain was [ __ ] up yeah that's what I
mean well here's the thing and Frank who
was 18 they're like look the killer came
in through this little panel in the door
that they had printed he was a huge dude
he was like a bit like six foot two or
six or 30s yeah wouldn't fit through the
that I was thinking just the the profile
of these homicides this is this this is
a slightly built person this is Sun
glare yeah cat burglar type and he's
also somebody who really doesn't had the
physical power to go with you toe to toe
when you're ready for him yeah I mean
yeah yeah he's kinda he's kind of he's a
weakling really is what it is that's why
he's going that's why he's going for you
while you're asleep yeah surprise
attacks because a lot of these killers
that really revel in the kill and also
have physical strength and power they
want you to be awake they want you to
talk with them they want you to get on
mercy yeah they want you to feel small
and puny in front of them they don't
want any of this I'm gonna sneak around
Casper yeah this is sneaky [ __ ] yeah
Casper [ __ ] is that's that's cuz you
don't have any of the strength to go toe
to toe that's what that is yeah and I
think that's probably I think what
happened was is that she got bashed over
the head and her head got jumbled you
know her brains got jumbled up maybe the
last person she saw was that the
neighbor was that mentioned I know
somehow the neighbors did it
well you're writing brain damage can get
you to think some crazy [ __ ] too well
yeah you know like turkey necks turkey
yeah my yeah my dad thought that the
doctors installed turkey necks into his
damn chest yeah for his heart bypass yes
what you talking about
Turk I saw him put turkey necks he had
them turkey necks in there remember I
tell you about the neighbors take care
of my dad there's a black family lives
across the street they're military when
he deploys guys why he's a sergeant his
wife looks out for my dad my dad's
elderly she brings him turkey necks he
loves those things well she came to
visit him in the hospital that day
of the bypass surgery in Africa out of
the surgery he was convinced the doctor
put turkey necks in his because he was
thinking of the turkey necks this is
brought him yeah her name is Clarice and
Clarice brought him turkey necks not
that night but Clara niece would
regularly bring him southern and he
loves color you see that it's he saw
Clarice and went into surgery and turkey
necks she was her connects way into his
heart I was talking what the hell is he
talking about she's on some kind of
medication you know no he had Hospital
psychosis my dad lost his damn mind and
thing about this story he was on certain
drugs coming in and now need a heart
attacks he kept shocking him and I guess
he kind of checked out mentally for a
few days and was hallucinating the
funniest thing about this was that when
you told me that about this story cuz he
you know he was gone for two weeks he
was in Mississippi I'm like calling me
and telling me what was going on and he
said that when he told his dad hey
there's no turkey necks in your chest I
don't you know I don't believe that or
whatever your dad what did your dad say
that's your prerogative yeah yeah yeah I
believe you there's no - that's your
progress there were turkey necks in
there man it would be rejected yeah I
know doctors not gonna put a we just fit
out the turkey necks so him put turkey
necks in that dumb I had a whole handful
I'm not gonna believe that cuz I speak
actually I speak in my normal dialect to
my dad but she hears me talking my dad
it's so so funny he gets more and more
like southern I get longer he talks to
his dad on the phone in the matter I get
really [ __ ] and if you get back
he's talking southern start talking
about how handy nation I got but I said
I'm not gonna believe that he put turkey
necks in there that's young pariah
that was the best part that's something
about that is just very very okay but I
think yeah this got it all straightened
out and then he called me I would thing
in Clarisse she gave me turkey necks and
she came and visited me that day and I
could just went in there and I was going
underneath the surgery and I was
thinking about them turkey necks
actually I didn't know why people hate
them turkey neck Barry brought me plated
him turkey necks damn good good I
understand it now I love that a lot of
meat on it you got a pan the bones I
mean I love Turkey in general I can't
eat turkey sandwich every day
southerners can make anything taste good
and you know they can't afford all this
room mostly by deep-frying it deep-fried
that [ __ ] deep-frying makes everything
taste good probably sugar on it probably
even a turd would taste good put sugar
on it if you seriously put peanuts in it
like coca-cola you put peanuts in it
I've never done that my grandmother does
that this real super white trash it's
imminent bag of peanuts you pour it in
your glass of coca-cola yeah actually
Coca Cola's high-class man you post me
drinking RC ya RC RC yeah although my
grandmother drank Coke her whole entire
life she never drank water she never
drank milk nothing like that teach me
high note I'm not the new nehi the old
me hi the old me hi yeah it was like
cream peachy peachy cream soda it's like
a cream soda with a slight peach flavor
yeah good sound anymore I don't see how
that original breast
I ain't you drink the grape nehi every
now
and it didn't have high fructose corn
syrup with me with sugar cane sugar cane
sugar yeah see now that's one of the
best things
what is time to be alive you guys is
that now a lot of the soda companies
have you know have versions where it's
like actual cane sugar like you can get
Mexican Coke that actually does taste a
lot Mexican Coca Cola's a lot better
than American coke
it really is that [ __ ] syrup is just a
weird I mean I don't
I'm not a big soda fan anyway never have
been since I was little but there's
something kind of there's an old guy
used to work worth tasting who's the old
man I used to work with who used to
deep-fried [ __ ] in motor oil back in
Depression era and I was like what the
hell you talking about they didn't have
detergent in the motor oil back then you
put it in your hair like pomade and I
was like what oh yeah gasoline on your
hand wash it for wash your clothes in
gasoline make him smell good yeah I
couldn't believe this old guy was
telling me this yeah people used to wash
their clothes and gasoline died in the
90s and he was in and he was in his 90s
yeah so guy named Jimmy you know one of
the oldest [ __ ] salesmen we had Jimmy
had run dude he was even cool dude in a
certain way you repeat himself a lot but
he said you know I know that they never
should have put that carpet in their
sodas it's making everyone does it
hey everybody got fat guys we used to
drink two or three to agree to do stick
pets at coca-cola every day never never
gained a pound yeah yeah and I believe
he's right now well the thing about
infant plus they put it in things that
you don't expect it yeah in bread I
think what they were doing with it we
did we got rid of that sugar and and
they put that corn syrup in there I said
that's what you feed cattle you feed
cool ready for corn you know you make
them fan you can kind of fat gonna get
fat and look it's way jr. talk well
that's the thing see my grandmother
whole whole life like I said she drank
coca-cola sheet little Debbie's the
whole entire life she
whatever she wanted she goes Debbie's
she never weighed more than 95 pounds
what our little Debbie's by the way
little Debbie's of you could get whole
it's like the way it's like the way
trash yeah yeah there's these little
cakes you put a picture of that all this
it's a company that makes pies and cakes
and [ __ ] and they're this cheap you
cheapest [ __ ] you can imagine like for a
dollar fifty get huge pac-12 oh they
used to be 99 cents make 99 cents for a
little yeah for like twelve
everything basically boiled down to
[ __ ] vegetable shortening and sugar
that's really what it was that was the
main you could bake it make it a cake or
you could make it remember the little
zebra cakes zebra cakes itch that was my
favorite cakes and then you can and the
donut sticks for donut sticks coffee was
like fall yeah and and they were they'd
make you fat and my grandma loved the
honey Bonnie had a slide it was not
Little Debbie then everything was kind
of waxy a little bit yeah that had a
waxy flavor to them because the the
frosting was mostly wax yeah I'd like
that though it had some kind of it was
almost kind of like Oh Matt it was what
is this [ __ ] they put on the outside of
winning cakes fondant fondant like yeah
it was kind of like fondant but it's
like kind of hard and then they come but
like a little moon pies yeah everybody
liked the oatmeal Pie oatmeal pies it
was - oatmeal cookies with a sandwich
marshmallow in the middle and it was
about that yeah it was a soft yeah you
put any of that stuff in the microwave
see we're we're saw there were XY
trailer-park you know good
Danna sausage okay now I never like this
my dad was into him that I liked there
my grandmother loved that pickled eggs
and calves brains
I didn't heed that she bought that
though jar in head cheese white hominy
hominy grits grits with cheese grits are
in season they're that the grit trees
are in full bloom he makes really good
grits you guys he makes grits
he puts cheese bacon and hard-boiled
eggs yes they're delicious
Toni's Cajun season yeah but really I
mean you eat a bowl of that that's all
you need to eat all day long half cheese
ya know what I was gonna say about the
little Debbie's the zebra cakes which
were my favorite ones they also did
seasonal variations which are kind of
the same they have little Christmas
trees for Christmas they have little
pink hearts with white [ __ ] on him for
Valentine's Day you know
but they you know they had those and it
was the same kind of thing which is like
a white cake with like white frosting in
the middle and then it was like this
fondant that's funny
hostess was high class compared to
Little Debbie then they had no Nutter
butters remember those things yeah they
were kind of like a wafer chocolate
covered
wafer cookie with peanut butter in it
like if you don't enjoy peanut butter if
you're some kind of heathen foreigner
that doesn't enjoy peanut butter go
ahead and not subscribe it well any kind
of any kind of nut butter yes sign me up
for that yeah cashew butter that's right
almond butter yeah peanut butter banana
sandwiches peanut butter but I don't
like bananas my peanut butter and banana
and honey on toast sandwiches okay well
yeah uh-oh I'll have the peanut butter
and the honey in the butter when you
spend a minute all these southern fried
rednecks
dressed the way they're dressed in those
bellies and shins because they're eaten
what we're talking which I that's what I
eat when I was a kid yeah yeah all right
so before we went off on that huge
tangent yeah before I had it I'm into
health food now you and your protein
shake yeah yeah yeah I can't eat like a
southerner anymore it they all gone can
they're all died out they're all dying
and that's good yeah my dad is just
struggling with it he was raised on a
bottle that not only had milk in it but
it also had bacon drippings in it
because in those days a mother gave
their sons and all their kids
pork fat bacon drippings and
good Mickey healthy yeah of course
bulky uh if you're fat and you're
healthy you're not starving all right
yeah but southern but my grandmother was
like that too and she was like skit like
I said she was thin as a rail her whole
entire life no matter how much cake she
ate which you know I wish I'd gotten
those jeans but I did not um but she
would like if you were not eating like
thousands and thousands of calories a
day she thought there was something
matter with you
yeah are you sick southerners lieutenant
towards fat but I'll tell you one thing
growing up coming to this South every
summer you know cuz I didn't live in the
summer wall-to-wall all the time you
know cuz only my dad was so that my
mother was there but I tell you yeah
I'll tell you one thing though
southerners southern when you talk about
North America southern women wear the
cutest women in it in in the United
States they were very good-looking a lot
easy Hollywood actresses you wouldn't
know but their southern they even go to
schools to change the accent Parker
Posey is a girlfriend Mississippi I know
her I grew up with her Parker Posey yeah
and she was a pretty she was one of the
prettier girls in town her dad was Chris
posed to heal the Chevrolet dealership
in Laurel ok and her brother Chris who's
a twin brother
well probably one of the better-looking
guys in town but yeah the South had
really good-looking people in it I'm not
sure it does anymore cuz lock you've
moved away yeah all the best-lookin yeah
I move away except me I'm most
Mississippi Mississippi actually he's
like mostly Mexican and Vietnamese now
they moved in because everybody's left
I mean Florida kind of sucks too but I
mean at least we live in Orlando where
there's actually like [ __ ] happening
Florida doesn't suck though Florida's
the new California yeah it is the thing
that sucks about it is it's hot
yeah it's hotter than [ __ ] there's a big
huge cockroach
we got to get back on on you're the one
that went off and everything I'm
drinking though I
we'll sell mine okay all right so here's
the thing and what we got started about
with the turkey necks and I'm sorry I
remembered it turkey necks but this goes
to show that [ __ ] you say when you have
a head injury
yeah can put other people's ass in a
sling and this is not cool because okay
Rosie cord Amelia which if you'll you
know remember was one of the victims of
the axe man of New Orleans who survived
she said okay you're Linda Giordano and
his son Frank are the perpetrators they
put them on trial and you're lando got
life in prison this was an old man and
Frank seems to hang he was 18 years old
damn so there's no way they could have
done it right and then it's just so it's
like they're in there for like nine
months or a year or something like that
and finally Rosie comes out and goes oh
my bad um they didn't do it I just said
it to be an [ __ ] pretty much and they
had to let them out she said it to be an
[ __ ] she said it cuz she said that it
was that it was spite and jealousy
that's what she said okay so I don't
know spite and jealousy for what I don't
know I don't know if it was because they
were a rival grocery store cuz it was
across the street cuz they ran a bursary
too so I don't know she just like oh I'm
gonna like ruin these people's lives
awesome I'm like that's not cool chick
no please don't do that I don't care
what she hate a person don't accuse them
of murder that's not goal so the next
thing that happened only a few days
after this projector the attack on the
court Amelia family in which like I said
their toddler daughter Mary was killed
the axe man or someone purporting to be
the axe man sent a letter to The Times
Picayune zodiac style but presiding AK
and it was dated March 13th now much
like Jack the Ripper he said that it
came from quote/unquote hell he
addresses it to the esteemed mortals of
New Orleans could listen to this [ __ ]
this is so I don't know this is so edge
lordy this he says this is what he says
in the letter I don't want it you know I
could read the whole thing I guess but
he says they've never caught me and they
never will course no they have never
seen me for I'm invisible
yeah he's a Casper even as the
sir that surrounds yeah Casper the ghost
I'm not a human being there you go
but a spirit and a demon cold hot as
hell yes told you though I said wait
till we get to the letter Park yeah he's
Casper I am want you Orleanians and your
foolish police call the axe man okay
when I see fit I shall come and claim
other victims
I alone know whom they shall be that's
an improper use of the word whom there
an axe man so I'm just saying I shall
leave no clue except my bloody axe be
smeared with blood and brains of he whom
I have sent below to keep me company
another improper use of whom if you wish
you may tell the police to be careful
not to rile me of course I am a
reasonable spirit I take no offense at
the way they've conducted their
investigations in the past in fact
they've been so utterly stupid as to not
only amuse me but his satanic Majesty
yeah but tell them to beware tell them
let them not try to discover what I am
for it were better that they were never
born than to incur the wrath of the axe
man I don't think there is any need of
such a warning for I feel sure the
police will always dodge me as they have
in the past they are wise and know how
to keep away from harm most undoubtedly
you Orleanians think of me as a most
horrible murderer which I am but I could
be much worse if I wanted to if I wished
I could pay a visit to your city every
night at will I could slay thousands of
your best citizens and the worst for I
am in close relationship with the Angel
of Death okay so he's had a mercy on him
right
that's what I mean he's about 5 foot 3
he knows about 90 pounds likes to read a
lot of books he he prior read Gaston the
Rope yeah you know this has given me a
failed poet type of value because that's
like some [ __ ] the fan would say family
awkward yeah and the drama queen right
here he's a ho then he says now he makes
a specific threat and like I said I'm
not sure if this is the guy that was
actually doing the killings or just
somebody that was doing it for sickness
shits and giggles now he says now to be
exact at 12:15 earthly time on next
Tuesday night which would have been
March 19th I'm going to pass over New
Orleans pass over like an angel
yeah or like Santa Claus like I said on
BuzzFeed I'm self except an ax-murderer
no rads got in my radar right there's an
app for it
tracking the x-man yeah in my infinite
mercy yeah I'm going to make a little
proposition to people here it is I'm
very fond of jazz music okay and I swear
by all the Devils in the nether regions
hit his ass I'm assuming yeah that every
person shall be spared in whose home a
jazz band is in full swing at the time
I've just mentioned if everyone has a
jazz band going well then so much the
better for you people one thing is
certain and that is that some of your
people who do not jazz it out on that
specific day night if there be any will
get the ax well as I am cold and crave
the warmth of my native Tartarus and it
is about time I leave your earthly home
I will cease my discourse God he's so
pretentious that's him
hoping that that will publish this that
it may go well with thee I have been am
and will be the worst spirit that ever
existed either in fact or realm of fancy
signed the x-men yes una yeah that's it
did anyone die now this was published in
The Times Picayune newspaper in New
Orleans yeah and like I said reg he said
that March 19th Tuesday night if people
didn't play jazz music he was gonna kill
him so everybody did they said New
Orleans that night everybody had jazz
records planner all the bands were
playing they stayed up all night they
had parties at their house wooden balls
everything that's what I mean they said
they had this whole big thing and like I
said this is actually part of the urban
legends the whole thing that was like a
song written about it later called the
ax man's jazz a whole bunch of short
stories have been written but poppy
seabright wrote one there was a whole
bunch of other ones that you know kind
of went into this kind of aspect of it
there were no murders that night so I
guess he was his garden
I guess he was happy with the amount of
jazz that was trying to get laid I
suppose so
the next attack actually didn't have him
for several more months the next one
didn't happen until August 10th 1919 and
this was Steve Boca yet another Italian
grocer now he woke up in the middle of
the night and saw a dark figure lurking
over him in the darkness he was hit in
the head with
blunt side of an axe they believe now he
actually woke up and he ran across the
street to his neighbor's for help
without realizing that his head had been
bashed and so actually you know they
they actually ended up saving him he was
alright now same kind of thing the back
door had been you know panel been
chiseled out day it's kind of [ __ ] no
nothing taken nothing yeah next attack
was September 3rd 1919 this was Sarah
Lehman she was 19 years old and she
lived alone so evidently they she Oh sue
she's laying there she's the person
bashed her in the head she knocked
several of her teeth out they found the
bloody axe in the house or in the front
lawn rather but she she lived but also
could not remember what the person
looked like everyone just remembered him
is like a hulking black shadow that's
pretty much all they ever saw the last
person that was killed by the axe man
was a man named Mike Pepitone II and
this was an attack that happened on
October 27th 1919 now he was killed
while his wife and they had six kids so
I'm assuming that the six kids were also
still in the house but he was the only
one that was attacked you know his wife
and kids were not harmed so evidently
it's in the middle of the nights like
1:00 in the morning his wife hear
screaming coming from the bedroom
because I she was sleeping in another
room or on the couch or whatever and she
runs in there Mike Pepitone II is his
head is bleeding everywhere I believe he
had been struck 18 times and died a
little while later and as far as they
know that was the last of the Axman of
New Orleans murders now the crazy thing
about this is that really they have no
[ __ ] idea who this person was they
have no suspects no nothing really the
only suspects that they have kind of
happened later on probably the most
famous one like I said some people have
said oh it's the Mafia some people said
oh it wasn't all the same killer
blah-dee-blah
you know some people even said it was a
superhit was a real demon you know which
you know that's dumb but one of the most
Amos kind of theories about it was put
forward by the crime writer Colin Wilson
now he thinks that the axe man was this
dude named Joseph mumphrey
the thing about Joseph mumphrey is that
urban legend says that the widow of Mike
Pepitone II who was the last person to
be killed by the axe man that she later
moved out to Los Angeles and married
another dude and so her name was Esther
and apparently the person she married
was named Albano's so she became Esther
albano now like I said it's an urban
legend that later on in Los Angeles
Esther albano shot and killed this
person named Joseph mantri because he
was the axe mated because he had killed
her husband
however when another crime writer looked
into this he could not find I'm not
saying it's not true
he could not find any police records of
anyone of either name in Los Angeles at
the time there was no crime you know
relating to that time there was no
Esther Elba Esther albano that had
killed her husband so he could get ahold
of her and then he confessed it to her
wife that I killed your husband order to
get you she shot him well I don't think
there was any of that going on but like
it so cuz like I said I think this is an
urban legend yeah it's gotta be cuz no
I'm not buying them because they
couldn't really find anyone by that name
in Los Angeles at the time and that one
minion right
nobody had been murdered nobody had been
you know and I don't really know other
than this urban legend I don't think
there's any other record of what
happened to Mike pepper Tony's Widow
after he was killed you know some people
thought that this last attack was maybe
mafia-related blah-dee-blah but I don't
really know how much of that I believe
now there was actually an earlier crime
that some people thought might have been
related to the Axman murders and this
was another Italian couple their last
name was chambre and they were actually
killed in the Lower Ninth Ward in May of
1912
however they were shot so if this now
the interesting thing and this may be
where the urban legend came from the
main suspect in this case
according to newspaper accounts at the
time was named mom fray or mum fray they
kept saying that last name it's not an
uncommon last name from New Orleans
during that time period and they never I
don't think they ever convicted the
person that did this
but because the mo was so different I'm
not sure if this was actually an Axman
crime like I said he didn't usually
shoot people he usually used an axe or a
straight razor so I'm not sure if this
is related or not but this mate this
might be where the urban legend came
from where that name has been related as
been kind of connected with that other
than that that's pretty much as much as
they know about the axe man like I said
it's it's a very famous unsolved case in
the United States and there's been like
tons and tons of fiction stories written
about it like I said it was on American
Horror Story there's been [ __ ] songs
written about it all kind of [ __ ] but
the interesting thing as famous as this
case is as I said the case I'm gonna
talk about the second part the mulatto
axe murders was way way worse like way
way more victims and it's almost
forgotten like I said I had never heard
of it so got take a break then yeah so
that's kind of crazy so all right so
that's the axe man of New Orleans case
and you know we went off on a lot of
tangents our people don't care if it
goes long yeah that's what I mean it's
it's fine we get like you care that goes
long go ahead but yeah so I'm gonna
paint another drink yeah yeah I'm
writing a cool card already I think I
might need one too actually although
this last part this last case is like
kind of complicated so maybe okay maybe
I shouldn't but I'll be able to hold it
together I probably will do you think
yeah although how funny would that be
you guys if you just if you just kept
drinking then he just like what just
fell out of the chair that would be
[ __ ] Elena you don't need to worry
about turkey necks yeah I have to stop
like triggering him yeah but yeah so
we're gonna take a break right now and
then I will come back and talk about the
fascinating case of the mulatto
also notice that voodoo axe murders
which may be a case of a female serial
killer
if this was the actual person that did
it so we will be back in just a couple
minutes to talk about that okay
everybody Jenny's got some new shirt
designs up four of them really good ones
to Atlanta Ripper who put Bella in the
which out the HH Holmes murder castle
and of course demon child cuz man said
he could these are updated designs I
think they look really cool Jenny did a
great job autumn where they found making
Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out very good
they're very high-quality shirts Jenny
and I we're sure our own shirts at
certain times when we're trying to put
spotlight on ourselves and you can put a
spotlight on yourselves if you go ahead
and pick up on these shirts today you
guys are gonna love them links in the
description
WWL calm at 13 o'clock yeah so go check
out our store at wwl calm slash 13
o'clock we got these four cool new
t-shirt designs plus all our old ones if
you'd rather get one of the old ones but
these ones are awesome and you should
check them out they're also available
women's cut and they look really cute
JT's got some so thank you go check them
out
what you're doing what's he doing hey
why are he so funny
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century volume 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format alright we're back from
the break on this axe murder II type of
show yeah we actually took a walk we did
in between you know you guys yeah like a
champagne for Christmas so seem like
we're having some alcohol because we
don't want to drink in the middle of the
day seventies style show you know the
main like on Merv Griffin where'd you
know smoking and drinking while they're
on the show maybe we should get some
cigars or something are we yet some
Charlie smokin we did a long time ago
yeah from yeah we started vaping
cigarettes didn't realize yeah put it
down yeah I feel a lot better yeah well
of course and I'm glad you did too
because you know I want you around for a
while I am smoking about about four
years three yeah I think it's been three
more
yeah because I think we stopped in like
October yeah I've told you because we're
probably by now yeah you're belongs
probably look like a baby to them no
stop it some larger yeah all right so
this next case we're gonna talk about
like I said this was something and me a
true-crime junkie I had never ever heard
of this case and apparently a lot of
other people haven't heard about it
either cuz I don't see a whole [ __ ] ton
of stuff about this this is kind of like
I said an Atlanta Ripper situation where
there were apparently a [ __ ] ton of
victims but because most of the victims
were black or mixed-race it seemed like
there wasn't a lot of media about it
there wasn't a lot of [ __ ] going on
couldn't sell newspapers oh I guess not
but that's the thing so I'm in those
days there's like two separate countries
what was happening with black people
that was happening with them the country
wasn't worried about that all the white
only the white people were the country
honestly like that was happening in
another country yeah like I found a
website that had transcribed like a lot
of the newspaper reports of these crimes
like from the time and like the way they
talked about the victims it's just it's
so like I don't shade on well I know
intellectually like that that's how they
refer to feel but it's like they're
talking about them like they were a
different species yeah something like
that it's like the weirdest [ __ ] yeah
okay and like I said you know I grew up
in a southern family I know you know my
grandparents kind of talked like this a
little bit it was at times you know it
was like those people were foreigners
and they weren't part of America so yeah
words like back in they have their own
ways and let them handle it and this was
even like way before my grandparents
were born this is even before the Axman
of New Orleans case and this actually
happened across Louisiana in Texas they
think there are somewhere between 35 and
49 victims of either the same person or
purportedly a gang of killers and we'll
kind of get into that in a minute now
the first case that they think might
have been related to this although it's
not usually putting like the canonical
victims but it's a pretty similar mo
happened in November of 1909 again this
is a type of thing where it's
buddy sneaking into a house where
everyone is when everyone is sleeping
and axing everyone in the family to
death usually an entire family you know
husband and wife kids sometimes just
wife and kids so that's kind of the kind
of thing that's going on here again
nothing stolen no other reason for them
to be in there so the first one was
actually happened in rain Louisiana
like I said in November 1909 this was a
woman named Edna Oba lusus and her three
children all killed with an axe the
first one that is canonical in the list
actually didn't happen until a bit later
it was January 31st 1911 and this
happened now is it Crowley or Crowley
Louisiana you lived in Crowley it's krob
that's what I was so well yeah but my
cousins are from there yeah
born in there yeah so as crows this
happen in Crowley Louisiana again this
was a whole entire family Walter Byers
was the name of the Father and then he
had a wife and a six-year-old son all of
them killed with an axe the killer left
the bloody axe behind at the scene also
left a bucket full of blood that they
apparently took from the victims so you
know there was that whole thing - the
next one that happened was a little less
than a month later actually having
February 25th 1911 this was the Andrus
family and this happened in Lafayette
Louisiana this was the dad's name was
Alexandra Andrus and his wife's name was
Mimi they had two kids Joaquim who was
three years old and Agnes who was 11
months old now these had all but this
this is super creepy
so whoever had come in had like you know
axe them all usually with the blunt end
of an ax just [ __ ] you know it's
fractured all their skulls or whatnot
now after the person killed them they
took the man and woman and like posed
them on the bed as though they were
praying like in one hat like one looked
like they were praying and then the
other one like had their arm around the
other one so this is a person this is
some weird ritual is diction this isn't
just kind of like you know I mean this
is a black family yes okay yes they
pretty much all were
like I said some of whom were mixed-race
or or were families where it was like a
black man and a white woman right or
advice for you know what I mean so it
was the the victims were pretty much all
all that right so yeah so there's that
whole thing now after this particular
crime they did actually arrest a person
named Garson Godfrey and he had actually
escaped from a lunatic asylum and they
found him at his mom's house however
after they arrested him and they
questioned him and they questioned like
other people they actually arrested his
mom too I don't know why for I guess for
harbouring yeah because he had actually
escaped from so you know so they
arrested her and they asked about around
about him but apparently he had been in
another town and he had like all these
people like saying that he had been
there so they eventually had to let him
go so you know they they kind of made a
connection between the previous crime
and they're saying well this is probably
the same person but at this point they
have no idea who it is
now the next one that happened happened
in March 23rd nineteen eleven now this
happened in San Antonio Texas which as
you'll realize it's quite a long way
away but this the reason they call these
like the Southern Pacific murders
sometimes I've seen them called that
it's just because some of the murders
took place like along that railroad line
as though someone was going from town to
town on this particular train it was
killing people and has gone back forth
so this next one happened in San Antonio
Texas again is another family of five I
look I don't want to say I love but the
newspapers at the time they always say
that the victims were brained with a
knife yeah so imagine a head smashed in
the head so that their brains were
sticking out I was the same as what they
mean but they always use that verb yeah
so yeah so this was the next one now
this is weird because the newspapers at
the time actually said that the couple's
name was Alfred an Elizabeth casts away
but some other sources I saw said that
the guy's name was Lewis casts away so
I'm not sure entirely maybe that was his
middle name I don't really know but yes
so they had three kids
and they were all axed to death these
here was something creepy about this one
now again these were all kind of
arranged in a particular order now
either one of the victims or all of them
had their faces covered
now that reminded me of guess what
Villisca yeah because that's what they
did in Villisca didn't they it's like
they kept they killed all the people
with an axe he went back and smashed him
again in the head to make sure they were
dead and then he covered up everyone's
heads like with blankets or curtains or
color you want to really don't want to
see the faces and you want to see the
grisly yeah he was trying to cover up
their identity yeah kind of dehumanize
him to make himself feel better yeah
that way you know felt like they weren't
there anymore that's kind of one of
things so I don't know if this is like
the same person
but probably common reaction to be a
NATO oldest Pookie house without any
electricity under the candle lights yeah
probably damn pretty damn creepy to see
the face of a corpse so they just
covered it up seating it a look at yeah
I guess so but I mean this one this is
like [ __ ] creepy because one of the
kids was baby he was six months old also
smashed in the head you know they had a
three year old daughter and they thought
like she was found like with her head
all bashed in she was like across her
mom's legs like she had been trying to
crawl away from the person they were
just like it's just horrifying so again
they have no idea who this could
possibly be now on March 28th which was
five days later they actually did make
an arrest but this arrest was for the
first murder which happened in rain
Louisiana now this was a person named
and I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing this
correctly but this person was named SAS
Osman II Giri and they arrested him in
relation to the first murder which had
happened which was Guidry yes
Guidry is one of the most common yeah
last names in Louisiana yeah yeah so
they arrested this guy but apparently
they couldn't you know they
and have enough evidence and they never
charged him with any of the other ones
and as far as I know they let that guy
go now that was kind of like a several
month gap now here's where things get
weird because in September of this same
year the police arrests this guy named
Raymond barnabutt sometimes called
sometimes spelled burn abet could be
Barnaby I'm not really sure it ends with
an G you know because I know they have
like thanks like Creole names and stuff
now I call him Barnaby yeah yeah now
this guy was apparently they actually
arrested him in connection with the
murder of the Andrews family so they
bring him in I'm not sure entirely I
think some sources have said that his
mistress turned him in or that people
saw him in the vicinity of the house or
whatever but in any case they brought
him in and they started to kind of build
a case against him now it didn't take
very long before he was it was only like
a little more than a month later that
they actually put him on trial now this
guy
Raymond Barnaby he had several children
now two of them one of them was named
Clementine it was his daughter she was
18 and the other one had a name like it
started with a zeal except for Rimmer's
that something like many and they both
testified at his trial that yeah our dad
is totally the killer you know he came
home that night said I killed that whole
damn family and he had blood all over
him and don't let him out or he'll kill
us and that they were afraid of him
right October 24th 1911 he's convicted
of those murders just the Andrews family
murders not all of the ones that had
taken place so far now while he's in
jail November 26 1911 there's another
one the Norbert Randall family and this
also happened in Lafayette Louisiana and
this was six people could the daughters
have been lying well yeah we're gonna
see well like I said there's a lot of
controversy about this and I couldn't
find a great deal about it I found a lot
of transcripts of like some of the
earliest you know some of the newspaper
accounts that came out at the time
but even back then they weren't super
sure about all of this so you know it's
this is a really fascinating case and
I'm actually shocked that it's not
better known especially like I said
since X amount of New Orleans is super
famous like everybody's heard of that
and that was you know six people dead
and six people wounded this one is at
least 35 if not way more this is yeah
this is Lana's whole killing spree just
wiped out yeah so yeah so this is the
thing where this whole family they lived
in like a three room house and their
oldest kid who was 10 she was their 10
year old daughter and actually been
staying at a relative's house and she
came home and found her entire family
had been slaughtered yes so you know all
of them dead in the band that does to
you that's what I mean it's like can you
ever can you imagine I can I can't
imagine I can't around the rooms and
they're all dead you see a guy killed
with an axe like all their heads bashed
in there's blood everywhere it's like I
can't imagine you going to shock you're
not really sure exactly what you're
seeing you're probably going to denial
then you go run for help it's probably
something kind of like that I would but
I imagine I mean how can you ever you
can't ever unsee that yeah even if you
tried to forget about it like in your
regular life it would keep coming back
like in your [ __ ] nightmares and [ __ ]
I just I hope I never see anything like
that in my whole entire life I mean I'm
saying the ability recover though will t
they do but you know so that's sad that
like the ten-year-old girl she found her
entire family had been axed to death now
at this point like I said now they're
like okay so rape and barnaby is in jail
still so they're like okay well
obviously he didn't do this one however
his daughter Clementine is a little
weird
so at this point they arrested her as
well now at first she said no I didn't
have anything to do with it it was my
dad blah-dee-blah
so but they keep her in custody because
they think there's something a little
fishy about her now a few days later
she's on the stand like at a hearing
and she confesses at first she confessed
to 17 murders that was the first thing
she confessed to now she we're gonna get
into this a little bit more later but so
you know but now while she and her dad
were still in custody there was another
family murdered that it was exactly the
same and that happened on January 18th
1912 this was the Warner family this
also happened in Crowley Louisiana um
this was actually a single mother her
name was Marie Warner and she had three
kids named pearl who was 9 Gary who was
7 and Harriette he was 5
this is [ __ ] horrifying so I read the
original like newspaper account of this
and it says and I quote do not get mad
at me this is a quote from 1912 another
horrible crime in the Kuhn town section
of the city I was just going really
really that would even consider racing
that's what I mean yeah it wasn't and
it's just like it's funny because they
can't ever just say the victim they
always said the name comma a Negro yeah
that's like they differentiate don't
worry it's not a white person right
they're trying to reassure you don't
worry reader this is not white person I
know this what happened over there in
their country it's intellectually I know
but it's yeah it's it's [ __ ] weird
delay was the culture in the times it
was another kind it was another time but
yeah so same kind of thing this entire
family killed with an axe and they think
that the killer like came in the back
door either broken or came in and it was
unlocked so he's so yeah at this point
like I said they still don't know
because they're two main suspects are in
custody when this happened now at this
stage Janie were like the day after that
particular crime they had said they had
found some clothing in the Barnaby
household that they thought belonged to
Clementine the 18 year old girl it was
in a closet that was it was not in her
bedroom but it was in like an adjacent
bedroom now I've seen different sources
say it was either a woman suit of
clothes or a man suit of clothes so I'm
not sure which one is which which ones
which but they found the suit of clothes
and apparently had blood and brains all
over it now different sources say
differing things at first one of the
sources said that Clementine said that
her dad had killed all the people and
that he had wiped the blood on those
clothes
another source said that she told
everyone that that was her blood like
she was she again 18
oh no no better 18 so this so you know
the day after the Warner family was
killed the chemist who had you know who
had been examining this clothing that
had the blood on it he determined that
the blood was you know belonged to the
victims and not to Clementine so at this
stage
Clementine gets charged with the murder
of the Randall family the wife and him
and the wife and the four children what
do we know about this Clementine girl I
mean not a lot honestly she sounds like
she might have a slight mental problem
well see like I said that's the
interesting thing about this case is
because one it was so long ago - I'm not
sure if she actually did do some of the
crimes or because there was so much [ __ ]
surrounding like oh she's of in a voodoo
call she was a voodoo priestess is this
make news that's what I mean and a lot
of the stuff that came out afterward
could have been manufactured yeah you
know what I mean because think of the
[ __ ] that was going on at the time like
who kills people and then just you know
automatically fesses up to it so easily
and and does the eighteen-year-old girl
actually have the means to wipe out
whole family see that's what that's what
kind of makes me initially back in back
in the early 1900s when an 18 year old
girl probably weighed 80 to 90 pounds
that's what kind of makes me that well
but that's what made this case so
interesting to me because here's the
thing when I was researching this case
because someone recommended it to me and
they said it's you know mulatto acts
murder so I searched for that and I
found a couple things and then I didn't
even
realize cuz a lot of the things that
were written about it were like oh they
were never solved who knows who did it
but then the more I looked they're like
oh well they were done by this girl
named Clementine you know named
Clementine and that she was a serial
killer she's even like on the female
serial killer list or whatever and she
had all these victims but the more I
look into it the more I'm like did she
really do it though or if she did she
for sure did not act alone because some
of the family murders took place while
she was in jail and while her dad was in
jail yes so I couldn't have been just
her if indeed she did any of them and
and these clothes that she said belonged
to her yes they did have blood and brain
matter on them evidently according to
the chemist but does that necessarily
mean I mean that may have meant was
there any physical evidence to link her
to these cases well other than that
blood on her clothes she said the
clothes were hers and she did she made
it efficient later but confessions yeah
and and and like what do we have of this
confession does the confession well I
have it I have it does the confession
confirm physical evidence at places
where she wouldn't have what you know
couldn't have accessed in other words
like you know if a person it you know
the the real killer always knows things
that the public doesn't right exactly
okay is there any of that in the
confession that I'm not sure because
like I said it's it's so hard to say
you're gonna have the details right was
a lot of gestation that she said like
she explained like why she did what she
did and she explained like what happened
in each particular place but the details
of it were not enough they were specific
but they weren't specific enough that
she couldn't have got it from the paper
and made up a story to fit what she had
so did she I'm not saying she didn't do
it well I'm not saying that what kind of
reasons did she give for well I'll get
to that in a little bit because like I
said at this point like I said the
chemist says that's they got crazy
people that can make all kinds of
comfort that's what I mean that's why
you can't ever ever have a sound and
very suspicious to me this sounds kind
of like what they would call a devout
mentally delayed person with some kind
of mental problems
what she may well be a bit and she'll
seeking and maybe being executed was a
way out of some kind of family misery
she didn't like the father or you know
alternately and this has happened a few
times too I mean I'm not sure if she was
literate or you know or anything like
that so they might have written the
confession said hey sign this been like
okay whatever or they might have beat it
out of that area at that time she
probably was illiterate
most people were and that's what I was
very early 1900s especially if you were
of the working socio-economic class
didn't matter if you were black or white
a lot of them didn't read it right yeah
you know I think middle class did yeah
you know but there were a lot of people
even you know when I was when I was a
boy visiting the South there were I
remember adults that were illiterate
yeah and they were from you know the
generation before me yeah it was I think
it's only very recently yeah that you
know literacy is 95 98 percent and
what's funny is that you know one of the
ones that I can think of you know was a
friend of the family and he ran a whole
business and couldn't read or write and
made a lot of money
well there's big yeah a lot of what he
had secretaries doing it all for yeah
and now he's an old man now and he did
eventually learn to read and write yeah
you know but that was I admire people
that do that when they gather again
anything's harder to learn yeah he did
it later on but he was he learned to
read and write by the time he was in his
mid-thirties yeah and I was a little boy
that but yeah yeah but so so here's
another thing
so Clementine and her dad Raymond are
still in jail at this point but then
there was another one
January 20th 1912 this was the Broussard
family this happened in Lake Charles
Louisiana so this was Felix Broussard
his wife and their three children
so obviously Clementine or her dad
didn't do that one because they were
still in prison now at this one the
killer left a note some sources say in
blood most of them
the newspapers at the time said they
left it in pencil it was actually a
quote from a version of Psalm 912 and it
said when he maketh the Inquisition for
blood
he forgetteth not the cry of the humble
and it was signed the human five which
means they didn't know what it meant so
at this point the press and the police
are starting to call this they're like
well we think that you know Clementine
and her dad are part of this larger
group which they started calling the
human five gang because they said you
know all of these family murders they
kind of had the perception that they
were all five victims and that it was
some kind of sacrificial or some kind of
ritualistic sort of thing even though
some of them are for some of them were
six you know it wasn't always five but
it did seem like that was the average so
they were kind of like talking about
that now I have seen some sources say
that this particular murder the children
that were murdered had little pieces of
wood like little planks of wood like put
between their fingers like spreading
their fingers out like like that you
know if you're watching the video you
can see what I'm doing but you know and
I've seen little drawings of it that
we're done not every source has this but
I have seen some sources where that so
that was again another kind of thing
where maybe this was some kind of like
you know five some kind of ritualistic
significance or some black hand or
whatever that type of thing is it sounds
far-fetched to me it does yes so but
like I said there was a whole since
these were you know african-americans
they were you know she I believe she
just spoke like Creole or French Creole
so they there was a whole voodoo thing
happening so it was you know good to
sell papers so I'm not really sure how
involved with any with any of that but
it sounds like a combination of two cops
trying to trying to come up with an
explanation and a bunch of newspapers
trying to sell copies of newspapers yeah
that's me
I don't know if I need to hear more this
I have to see the evidence firsthand
right now so all the confessions but I
have a feeling that those confessions
are kind of bogus
well like I said I have I found like her
pretty much entire confession which they
published in the paper so all real it
was that real that's what back in those
days our paper could print in that's
what I mean they could have printed
anything like I said could she even read
it did they just write something and she
was like sure whatever
especially Louisiana New Orleans area
south Louisiana I mean to this day I
mean you see Louisiana justice people
kind of laugh and not a man is very
corrupt it was always very corrupt now
right around the time that the Broussard
family was murdered um they also
arrested this other guy who was a pastor
and his name was King Harris now they
they're not sure like what his
involvement was he had this kind of his
little congregation now the story went
that there was an offshoot of his
congregation that was called like the
Church of sacrifice or the sacrifice
Church and they were into voodoo and
they were like into human sacrifice and
[ __ ] like that now he claims he didn't
know anything about that I kind of feel
like what might have happened is that I
think the church that he was pastor of
was called like Christ sanctified or
Christ sanctity or something like that
and I sanctified sacrifice some
newspapers right so I kind of feel like
there was a little bit of that [ __ ]
going on like a little bit of
exaggeration but they did arrest him in
you know
connection with some of the murders but
he you know insisted that he's like you
know the Randall family had been at one
of his sermons like one night or like a
night before they were killed or
something like that but other than that
he didn't know it to me and it sounds
like the police are going on a witch
hunt yeah it does kind of sound like
that they also a few days later they
arrested this other woman named Eliza
Richards they didn't really say why they
wanted her like in relation they thought
she was another member of this purported
voodoo gang or whatever it was but they
they put her in this particular prison
they said we put her over here because
we thought if they if we put her in
prison in Crowley then people would you
know because there was so much freaking
out about the crimes that people would
kill her
there Lynch her or whatever so there was
that I don't know whatever happened with
that woman but she was also arrested you
know there was also you know and over
the next couple months like this the
paper started reporting like you know
obviously the family's like in this
parts of Louisiana and parts of Texas
where this was happening you know black
families were like posting guards and
ferd of their house they were all arming
themselves you know they were all kind
of keeping a neighborhood why as you
would yeah they were afraid you know
even the police and the government state
and federal government and the police
didn't have the power then that they
have to didn't have the ability to man
power nothing and they didn't really
even feel that they kind of had the
responsibility yeah I mean people had to
take care of themselves back then if the
posses we're all about you know sheriff
you're coming okay you guys come on help
me go get this guy you know it's like
mob justice yeah and that's just you
know mob defense yeah so a lot of the
cops that are probably involved in this
are probably trying to figure out who's
you know who's killing all these black
people yeah I mean they just didn't let
people kill each other they would try to
stop so you know it wasn't a thing about
racism they would try to stop it just
didn't have the ability and the power to
do so right so kicking up dust and
making sensational news articles and
having cops on the scene part of that
was to encourage the people to hunt down
and figure out who it was that was
killing them yes the police so the
policeman had to do it just didn't have
the power well yeah you know the man and
you saw that like I said I saw that when
I was reading you know contemporary
police articles about the Atlanta Ripper
crimes they were all but saying outright
and the articles it's like wow we really
wish those black people would step up
and do something about this [ __ ] in
their neighborhoods right fine whoo this
isn't killer right say that outright but
it was that's what you talk about yeah
it was it was implicit just the invent
the investing techniques weren't
basically what they were saying is if
you know who this is kill him yeah you
know that's what they're saying yeah
basically I mean they didn't come out
and say it but that's clearly what they
were implying what they meant and it was
the same kind of thing here and like I
said a lot of neighborhoods they were
all arming themselves and [ __ ] like that
now there was actually another one on
February 23rd 1912 this one
the Dove family had he dove who was 30
she was the mother and she had some kids
ernest was her son who was 14 years old
she had a son named Ethel who was 16 and
also had a daughter named Jesse quirk
who was 18 who was actually married but
her husband she had broken up with her
husband the mother had also broken up
with her husband so same kind of thing
you know they were all killed with an ax
the ax was found at the house just like
an axe man of New Orleans they've been
leave them behind
they also found like a cloth that had
like bloody handprints on it like is
there the murder of wipe their hands off
they found that the axe that had been
used actually belonged to a guy that
lived only two blocks away but it was
weird because I feel like the the person
they said the the murderer had stolen
the axe from that guy's house and then
killed two people but then like left
another acts like he switched the axes
out you know what I mean yeah so he left
another axe hmm you know at that house
so now April 2nd 1912 Clementine burn a
bet or Barnaby or however you pronounce
Barnaby she makes a confession
quote/unquote that is printed in the
paper um she says what her name is she
says I was born and partly raised near
the town of st. Martinville la Louisiana
moved to Lafayette about three years ago
when I began to lead a life of
degradation okay which would you say
that I don't know I have never been
married that was the next thing it was
well in the company of two other women
and two men while in New Iberia
Louisiana that we met an old Negro yeah
who told us that he could sell us can
jazz or can DEA's words like hoodoos
like little you know voodoo things
meaning which with which we could do as
we pleased and we would never be
detected and would be protected from the
hands of the law by the mere fact of
them being in our possession we bought
them and paid three dollars each for
them and left New Iberia the same night
returning to Lafayette when we began to
plan our actions we had not yet decided
on committing any murders but it was
while we were discussing our future
plans that the question came up as to
whether we could kill and be protected
by the hoodoos so that's her story is
that they had bought and
I read this Imagi source yeah that she
had bought these things from a guy
purportedly named Justin Thibodeaux
he actually said I have no idea we're
talking but he was like a root magic
kind of guy like he you know he was kind
of the guy where you you had a wart and
you'd go buy some preparation from him
and your work would go away
but she said we bought these from him
and he said that we could do whatever we
wanted and we've protected no one would
see us the law would not call bullsh so
we decided we were gonna try that out
she's making that up that's what I mean
it sounds buried it sounds fishy she's
making that up
yeah people didn't think that people
didn't think that way even in the early
yeah why would you even think why would
that even a young girl can she's 18 this
is a young girl casting shade on
everybody she knows and doesn't like I
guess yeah so yeah so that's what she
says so she says there's a whole gang
and they got these things and they said
hey wouldn't it be funny to try these
out let's go in bust into people's
houses an accident our family to death
and see if we get caught to see if these
[ __ ] well I think the cops was her
whole thing I think the cops are on a
goose chase here now here's the
interesting thing though the next part
of her confession that was printed in
the paper she says it was sometime
during the year in 1910 I believe in the
fall that I went to rain Louisiana with
my companions and we drew lots to know
who would make the first attempt of the
hoodoos and committing murders now the
interesting thing though is that she
says during the year in 1910 I believe
in the fall now she's talking about the
first murders that took place in rain
yeah that wasn't fall 1910 that was fall
1909 so there's a contradiction right
there yeah so lying or did she just mean
that's what I mean so I'm not sure if
she mixed something up but that's a
contradiction I got I just got a weird
feeling about these kind of confessions
I think she's [ __ ] it sounds like a
crazy yeah sounds like she's ran she's
got her head it sounds like a crazy
story no Shannon basically says she says
I drew the short straw you know that's
not exactly what she said but that's
what she meant the lot fell to me
accordingly I got to work that night I
went to my sister who lived in rain
Louisiana near the railroad depot later
during the night went up
to town disguised as a man and securing
an axe in a yard near the cabin where I
killed the mother and four children she
said she picked the house because they
were simply lights on in the house and
so that was the one she was attracted to
on entering the house I struck the woman
on the right temple and killed her
instantly one of the children was
awakened by the noise and before he
could raise his head from the pillow I
struck him with a blow somewhere near
the left ear then I struck the other two
I left the man's clothes which I wore in
the house and left the house and a
woman's clothes returned to my sister's
house and later during the same mat I
boarded a night train for Lafayette
arriving there about midnight it was
about 9:00 when I killed now does the
evidence match the story see I don't
know because that first crime like I
said she's about a year off first of all
because that first crime if that was
heard that happened a year before she
said it because she gave the order in
which she killed him also the places
where she struck him yeah what she was
wearing in the clothes change I'd like
to know if that's really I never read
that the first crime I haven't read much
about that first crime because usually
like I said they don't really talk about
that one that much so I don't know if
they found like instead of bloody man's
clothes in the house or not I never saw
anything about that so I don't know she
might be she's talking out her ass yeah
that's no one else was investigated it
as far as you know like I said there's
not a little too old there's not a lot
of [ __ ] about this I was shocked at like
how little it's kind of like the Atlanta
Ripper case I was shocked at like how
little there's not even a book about
this one I think there's like um I think
there was some like a chapter in a book
about like crime in Louisiana yeah
but there's not a whole book of it I
mean at least Atlanta Ripper had one
whole book about it this one does taste
like this you might want to research
maybe even write a book about this I
know this is fascination I didn't know
anything about it do the research it's
easy to go there I know all these places
I could take you there yes yeah yeah we
can Suika check court records and see if
they still exist on a unison yeah but
you'd have to find out if these
confessions match that the evidence and
whether there were attorneys at the time
that brought up yeah her story matches
the evidence right good to find that the
thing about it that was that even at the
time like as long as this confession is
and she keeps saying there's other
people in her gang including her sister
and you know that she was the one that
got
asked with going to check out these
hoodoos to see if they worked and like
protected her and stuff and she did say
yeah we went in this house in this city
and killed these people and I killed him
in this order and stuff but like I said
a lot of it was in the papers at the
time she's gonna read you could have
just read it in the papers and just
repeated it or like I said the cops
could have written it and she just
signed it or whatever so you know I'm
not real sure and the thing about it is
that even at the time even in the
newspapers of the time in nineteen
[ __ ] twelve it said police are not
sure about the you know veracity of her
confession yeah because there were some
contradictory things in there like I
said she got some of the dates they were
smelling [ __ ] - it sounds like a
fanciful tale yeah and she named
accomplices that they could never find
like the dis girl teacher who exists
this girl's tripping and like I said a
lot of the family the murders of the
families happened while both she and her
father and her brother they eventually
put her brother in jail - were in jail
okay so obviously they couldn't have
done it right
so the fact of them you know was there a
voodoo gang called the you know the
human five gang is they were calling
them was this a voodoo gang this is a
neglected young girl trying to
grandstand and become important that's
what it is yeah like I said it sounds
like a crazy story and like they're not
even sure that this sacrifice Church or
whatever like this offshoot Church that
they were supposedly a part of and like
all these people know they're not even
sure if that existed they're just saying
yes she might have said that but like
everybody that was supposedly involved
in it were like we don't know what
you're talking about
sacrificed Church that sounds like
[ __ ] that's Catholic territory it'd
be something like Church of the Holy
Sacrament there's some [ __ ] like that
you know I mean I kind of feel like this
is some newspaper our lady is our Lady
of the lilies Church be [ __ ] I kind of
feel like a lot of this is kind of holy
hearts I mean obviously somebody did
this [ __ ] right obviously somebody broke
into these people's houses and axed all
these people to
probably multiple offenders what yeah
it's like was it her I don't know I mean
obviously she didn't do all of them I
kind of think this like multiple
offenders it comes up in the paper and
somebody else goes oh well somebody's
doing that I can do it too and then they
go do it and it becomes kind of like a
thing you have four or five guys out
there doing these home invasions and
smashing people
imagine people they don't like they'll
think the killer did yeah we talked
about that a little bit the accident of
New Orleans case where it's kind of like
if you get one or two crimes that are
similar that are sensational enough you
got other guys jumping on you're gonna
get other people going hey what a good
idea I'm gonna do that [ __ ] too because
you know people are weird you go well
they're going after people that they
have personal vendettas against right
and they'll just make it look like it
make it I think the killer did it right
you know so if you aren't that dumb yeah
people might be mean they might be crazy
but they're not dumb so after this big
long confession and like I said even
when the confession was printed in the
paper the last paragraph of the config
after the confession said you know
police are not sure how does how
seriously they take this because there
are some contradictory statements
blah-dee-blah
so you know like I said they're not
entirely sure now and also it should be
noted that first when her father was
arrested
you know she pretty much said yeah my
dad did all that [ __ ] sounds like she
just had a vendetta against her get to
dad maybe cuz like I said he was in jail
he was in jail before she was so
obviously even if sexual abuse it
wouldn't shock me honestly yeah there
might have been supposed am i tying in
with common neglected personality who
wants to feel important yeah so at this
stage
April 4th 1912 there's a grand jury
indictment and they're at this stage
they're I think they're accusing her of
six murders and she's confessed to I'm
not sure at this stage but I think 35
initially she confessed to 17 but then
the more they talk to her like it would
have to like them not by now like there
were about 40 murders during this time
so it's not like she was just pulling
murders out of her ass they were
happening yeah she didn't do it though
but I don't know if it was her what's
the physical description on this
eighteen year old I don't know
absolutely not one picture of her and
her face an 18 year old girl does not
have usually had the physical prowess to
pull off a long string of homicides like
this and get away with it and how often
does an 18 year old year older show
eventually somebody of such a somebody
of that description would run into
somebody that she would not be able to
handle yeah that they would just kick
her ass yeah because I mean other than
you know maybe Lizzie Borden which they
don't even know she did that [ __ ] or not
how often does a [ __ ] girl do this
kind of [ __ ] hardly ever
hardly ever doesn't it's not a girl's
women come blow that way that's it blow
up that way there are in general there's
a small percentage that do yeah but in
general if women are gonna kill people
and I think I mentioned this on our last
true crime show if women are gonna kill
people that usually poison yours I'll
smother you or they'll do it in a less
messy Angel of Death type and a less
obvious way in angel of death type women
it's easier to kill in patients not
gonna Munchausen by proxy killed off
kids that that kind of stuff yeah
they're not gonna go into a house and
like accent an occasional Aileen Wuornos
type but this ain't it and honestly it's
this year I'm thinking that what this
was was a crime wave yeah and I think it
was multiple offenders it may it may
well with with differing motives some of
them were trying to throw first-degree
murders for profit into the heap of this
is the killer doing it but really I just
want to pay my bill because see maybe
you owe money or you know what I mean
yeah you might owe somebody money says
well you know I'll just kill ya and
they'll think that the [ __ ] killer
did it so at this point they have
Clementine and they're like okay well
we're accusing her of six murders but
we're not going to we're not going to
arraign her for trial yet because we're
gonna wait and see if there's more
accomplices or if there's more evidence
or whatever so she's kind of just
hanging out in jail meanwhile they also
arrested her half-sister Pauline who
protests she's like I don't really even
know her so what the [ __ ] I'm white
arresting me they also arrest it just
name it people she don't like right
that's what I'm is like a witch-hunt
type of thing yeah and they were
probably encouraging her it's like hey
who else isn't she's probably just
pulling names out of her but she was you
know they also arrested this other woman
named Avelina Mabry who Clementine had
named you know as being an accomplished
in Iraq i guess but valina obvious she
said i don't know what she's talking
about I don't have yes maybe she does
now
April 13th 1912 while all these people
are in prison there was another one
yeah Antonia this was the family of
William Burton this was five people it
was his wife and two children and a
family friend named Leon Evers they had
all been their heads that all been
crushed in with an axe now a little bit
different in this one the male victims
actually had knives like plunged through
their bodies and were left there which
was kind of a new detail so whether this
was the same killer or not I'm not
really sure but you know so like I said
at this point there the cops are kind of
still running with this sacrifice Church
thing like I said the media are blowing
it out of the water it's like oh she's a
voodoo priestess and she has this gang
going to satanic panic route right and
that's what I'm saying
yeah I feel like this is kind of like
like I said at the end of this killing
spree and like I said there was a [ __ ]
ton of axe murders
in the early part of the 20th century
just like amazing just so many axe
murders
but this particular run was like 40
people yeah were they all the same
person don't know they were all very
similar but you know axe murders tended
to look kind of similar to one another
so might not have been now the fact that
none of them were robberies or anything
like that kind of gives you pause and
[ __ ] like that but I got it I just got a
weird feeling that this became a fad
yeah possibly it started showing up a
lot in the newspapers the way like a
satanic panic story so anyone out there
that had any kind of grudge or wanted to
get rid of somebody else you could do
this you could do a homicide that
matched that pattern yeah I hope that
you could piggyback it in on that
phenomenon
do it yeah that'll satanic church did it
you know I mean it's that kind of stuff
I kind of feel like but it might have
been guys not wanting to pay child
support or alimony or whatever it might
have been guys that wanted to get rid of
wives it might have been somebody who
wanted to get rid of neighbors or get
rid of people that they owed money to
stuff like that yeah it's like it's a
convenience keep you know oh there's a
serial killer running around I'm gonna
get in on that yeah yeah yeah now here's
something now I'm not sure how true this
is
but I did read in one source that the
panic surrounding all of these murders
shortly after the Burton murders the
Burton family murders in Victoria Texas
apparently there was a guy named Ernest
smothers and he you know they had all a
lot of the families have like armed
themselves over like you know posting
guards outside their house or whatever
so he's guarding his family house now
one of his friends drops by to make sure
his family is okay and makes the mistake
of just like coming in without knocking
and gets shot dead by his friend now the
creepy thing too is that somebody else
like another neighbor is like coming by
and he sees somebody on the porch and
he's like oh [ __ ] and he starts running
down the street back to his house cuz he
sees the dead person somebody else sees
that guy and it's like hey there's the
axe man and shoots that guy yeah
so I don't know how true that is but
I've seen that it became a panic right
so I've seen that a couple sources where
it's like everybody was armed and
everyone was paranoid and it's like you
know you'd see a person writing a street
you didn't know who was she questions to
my theory because everybody was arming
themselves that mean you know it was a
panic which means there'd be a lot of
people in the criminal world or just
people who want to get taken advantage
of and like I said you know it's
understandable that it was a panic like
I said it was at least 40 murders right
so it's not like it was nothing like no
I'm scared of nothing there was some bad
[ __ ] going on so he became a bad like I
was saying old family yeah yeah now
April 26 they actually arrested another
guy named Mack Thomas and also
clementines brother whose name is zephyr
and I just remembered they were also
arrested and put in jail because they
were supposedly part of
human five gang or whatever it was yeah
may 17th 1990 1912 the sheriff got a
weird letter and it was from somebody
who is not named they just say a Negro
that was all that mattered back it's
like they couldn't just by the way a
Negro came by a lot of times it even put
their names man the Old South was a
[ __ ] trip man they were fake this
little too seriously if you're out there
listen it was it was the absurdity of
the times we can laugh now because it's
over that's [ __ ] up yeah you get like
I'd be really sad if like I got killed
with an axe and then like in the paper
like a Caucasian cracker cracker was
killed with well you're like not even a
but the thing is those there there might
be you know you could hang out with you
can hang out with so like black
nationalists and that's how they write
it down and that's kind of like the way
it was the Irish they should do that
until it balances out yet the papers
were not actually written for black
people would be reading them that
audience was the white label so they
were always taking it from that point of
view by the way black people got killed
so don't worry yeah don't worry about it
just black nothing for you to worry yeah
that's what they're talking about yeah I
feel like they do it now but they're
sneakier about it like they use
euphemisms papers I don't know I know
pace newspapers still existed yeah so
they get this letter it's written in
pencil they said it was badly written I
don't know what that means exactly but
this person whoever it was allegedly is
confessed to the crimes and said oh I'm
in this gang and we have a leader and
he's the one that selects the victims
and we all go out and do his bidding or
whatever the police didn't really take
it all that seriously they were just
like whatever we're just gonna keep that
just in case they also arrested another
guy in June of 1912 who was another
preacher and his name was Jay s Anderson
or that's what his alias was they
arrested him
because he was kind of like a snake oil
salesman like he'd go from town to town
like selling what he called paradise
pills $10 a pill $10 in 1912 that's like
a thousand [ __ ] dollars right well
probably not but it was a lot right okay
yeah so and they thought that he had
been like in the towns where the murders
took place like around the time like
that was on his travel routes they
thought that was a little suspicious
they found out that his real name was SW
Goodman and he had actually been a
Baptist preacher a former Baptist
preacher in San Antonio and he escaped
from a penitentiary in Huntsville he had
only had a 4-year sentence I'm not sure
it was four but he had escaped from
prison and then he had kind of been
going around selling back you could run
from a prison yeah I guess you can't run
from a prison that you can't run from
computers weren't you in prison like I
said back in the old days so much easier
to come you just act the whole family
and they just move to the next town and
no one ever did [ __ ] they never catch
you well they never did yeah but so they
arrested this guy too
just cuz they said his itinerary looked
a little suspicious but I don't think
anything came of that either actually
Clementine Barnaby was brought up to
trial finally on October 24th 1912 and
found guilty yep I've been talking all
that [ __ ]
although the weird thing is that she
only ended up send it is serving she was
actually sentenced to life but they said
she only served ten years they said
because they did a vaguely something
procedure yeah on her that was supposed
to make her a quote-unquote normal
member of society it was like the
Ludovico tape that's the first thing I
thought this is Louisiana they said
she's safe now and she can get at me all
right yeah I mean I did 10 years she
served ten years that's not what
happened that's no way I'm sure it
wasn't no it's like that's very vague
what happened was is that they knew she
was lying Dan they felt kind of they
gave her ten a year like they gave her
ten years so they could get credit for
an arrest so it looked like look
justice was served and then they said
well we'll let her out ten years that
crazy [ __ ] we'll let her out they knew
she was alive and she's crazy I kind of
feel like yeah because I wrote about a
couple other cases in my book where you
know the people were convicted of a
crime but you could tell the cops and
[ __ ] didn't really think then like three
years they're like okay yeah parole
southerners might be kind of dumb and
they might be kind of crazy but they're
not stupid okay so might be dumb but
this is lying we know she's lying and we
got to give her life all right we'll get
the arrest credits and we'll say we
healed her and let her out ten years
from now and then that's exactly to be
awesome
it's like she's fine we rehabilitated
her southern is gonna find a way
somebody tries to punch her she'll throw
up everyone can look like a hero justice
sir I'm sure that's exactly what
happened in the panic will die down and
they'll stop acts and each other see now
I'm gonna say like I said there is no I
should note that there is no Wikipedia
page for the mulatto ax murders of the
Southern Pacific ax murders or whatever
you want to call them or the Voodoo
murders why is this how everyone oh I
don't know however there is a Wikipedia
page for her and it pretty much just
says yeah she did all these murders but
see I don't think I buy it item I'm not
saying look serial killer I'm not saying
there have been women serial killers and
there were probably more back then
because everyone was hard-ass yeah but
an 18 year old girl she didn't do this
thing entire families no I'm just not
buying it I'm not buying it [ __ ] is
crazy
I don't and the fact that so many of the
crimes took place when she was in jail
and what her dad was in jail so he else
did that she's my theory was was there a
voodoo gang no my theory is there she
was being abused in some way by the
father yeah so this is a way to get rid
of her father and it was a way of kind
of committing suicide
yeah all right they rigged it up to
where she did 10 years in jail but then
they let her out once her mind got right
that's you know what we'll put her near
she'll cool off and then she'll age
another ten year
she'll go out you know then should be
alright and we'll take the credit for
the arrest that's what that's what
happened I good old boys and then how to
hook that up yeah because so like I said
as much as you know Clementine is kind
of she's listed the couple times when I
searched her name she's kind of listed
oh so it's big female serial killer like
she killed 35 people she killed 49
people some like I don't know she killed
anybody I think she was a issues
fantasize and she was lying and I and I
really don't think that there was a
voodoo gang that just sounds not saying
like crazy [ __ ] happens all the time
that was a panic but that sounds like
yeah that sounds like some messes in the
south that would have been a good
moneymaker cuz you could write a lot
about in the newspapers and sell a lot
of newspapers exactly and think of how
many pews you could fill the churches
because in the south south is a [ __ ]
big Church is a big business and you can
go out and go yeah they out there people
they out there look at them with their
level food you devil devil working on
those people I know the [ __ ] people
they come in your house with ax smashing
each and every one of you
y'all know you need to come to the Lord
and like I said I'm not you know I'm not
downplaying cuz somebody did do that oh
yeah but he did come in people's houses
and smash all this little kids and
everything with an axe from the Gulf
Coast did she do it I doubt it I'm from
the Gulf Coast I know the culture well I
could turn the clock back to the early
1900's and see what a money-making
opportunity these crime wave would of
course for the establishment I mean you
see it a lot like I said I've read
several books about like that you know
you know late 1800s Early 1900s like the
wars between the newspapers there's a
lot more of them back in those days so
there was a lot more competition so you
know whoever had the most salacious
scandalous details and sold more copies
that was a win right so if they had to
make [ __ ] up they wouldn't you know what
I mean and the cops and the preachers
they knew it was all [ __ ] yeah no
[ __ ] that it did
believe that girl killed all those
people they would have hung her ass yeah
reason why they let her out is because
they knew she didn't do it yeah I kind
of feel I don't know yeah they found
some bloody clothes in her house but
there was other people living in that
house maybe she had a nosebleed I heard
there was brain matter on there to you
but I don't know man those guys will say
anything that's what I mean I don't know
so like I said that's from the paper but
who knows was that true
I don't probably not true I just I don't
know I'm not buying it like I said it
eight-year-old girl that's not they're
not usually axe murderers I don't even
I'm not even what did she do for a
living I don't know it takes money to
travel to all these places yeah it's
like one must Frances there's expenses
to be in a traveling serial killer think
about it well yeah and what and if she
would didn't have any money which I bet
you she didn't have any money well yeah
I'm very poor he's down in the Ninth
Ward she didn't have anybody she'd have
been robbing them people blind doctor
killed him yeah why why not take money
because I mean apparently like in a
bunch of the cases like there was money
left it was like money in the people's
pockets there was like money left there
was valuables left around and no one
took anything so because she didn't do
it somebody did it but I don't think it
was letting her I don't think it was and
I don't think there was a voodoo guy
just like when you have serial killers
today you always have a certain amount
of nuts that'll come for saying I did it
I did a confession to didn't do it's a
small percentage of people that she was
one of those I think it's just that back
in those days they didn't realize that
that said that that was the thing that
that was a thing yeah that's all it was
I always wonder about the psychology of
people that do that because there's
always a certain percentage every time
there's some like really big ticket you
know mass murderer or some kind of
serial killer something like that
there's always a certain percentage of
people that come for and go yeah it's a
type of masochism I guess so the the the
abusive relationship with the father I
think maybe I think he was you know
involved with the daughter her going to
the gallows and being hung for this
crime alleviates her from her sins I'm
Tom up yeah so like suicide yeah that's
what that is
and it reminded me of her confession to
the cops new yeah the cops knew her
confession reminded me very much of the
fanciful tales that women that were
arrested as witches yeah back in the
Middle Ages would come up with all this
stuff about you know yes I puckered my
lips and smooch the devil's backside
yeah his butthole kissed my mouth yeah
like all the [ __ ] they came up with like
like it had the ring of that you know
what I mean
and I feel like yeah she had a lot of
details about the crimes but a lot of
details about the crimes were printed in
the paper yeah cuz I read a lot of them
it's like I could have confessed to that
[ __ ] [ __ ] they printed the paper I said
I imagine the cops are skeptical because
some of the stuff that she was quote and
came out of newspapers and they knew
that that's not what the crime scene
really looked like and here's one thing
I saw one source because one of the last
ones they I'm guarantee you before you
go any further if Schiff if her stories
had checked out with the [ __ ] crime
scenes and they booth and the cops
believe that she did it she they two
killed her ass yeah this is [ __ ]
Louisiana David killed her one of the
crimes like Norbert Randall and I forgot
to mention this one I was talking about
that family and he murdered all of them
are killed with an axe blah blah but
Norbert Randall was actually shot now
she said in her confession that she shot
him with a pistol but she said she shot
him in the breast or the body but other
sources I read said that he was shot in
the head so I don't know how so I don't
know if that's another contradiction
like I said the thing that got me was
that she was saying that she had killed
the first victims the woman in her three
kids that she killed them in 1910 and
fall of 1910 when it was actually
November of 1909 when that crime took
place so yeah people can miss remember
things a few years later but you know
the fact of her saying yeah I shot that
guy but saying she shot him in a
different body in a different body part
that he was actually shot in yeah you
know that seems a little weird so I I
don't know I'm not this is a Louisiana
tale yeah that's all this definitely
needs a book all its own cuz this is a
fascinating and I had never heard of it
so I can't remember who it was that
recommended because it was a long time
ago but thank you for recommending he
wrote this right way
a good movie I watch it well like I said
I don't understand why they don't do and
they should do this in Atlanta Ripper
cuz it's going on about the same time
yeah you know I mean Atlanta Ripper
though yeah that was like 11 lanolin 11
same time I would do it in Atlanta I
think Atlanta ripp would be an awesome
[ __ ] a horror action flick along the
lines that Candyman that's what it made
me think yeah actually I got the shirt
Atlanta rip if you guys check out that
the land of Ripper shirt she made I got
what it's awesome yeah I think you were
wearing it on earth it did come out very
nice on the back it's got a full color
little medallion and me and Jenny in the
back of it I go to Mexico
yeah yeah alright so well let's kind of
wrap this up cuz I was gonna be like
another super long show god we go on
don't we especially like when we're
drinking it's Friday night it is
recording what I was it Friday not the
Friday they're getting it but they're
getting it on New Year's Day so Happy
New Year's again and also again remember
if you like the show to like share
subscribe and all your social media if
you'd like to financially support the
show you can get our patreon page which
is patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast
or go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast wordpress.com and there's a link
in the sidebar to a PayPal account if
you'd like to give a one-time donation
give us some money
also my audiobook like I said faceless
villain hey Liam to is finally finally
17 hours for what was it $24 70 to 95
yeah and it is 17 we're asking our and
we're selling 10 to 15 of them a day so
good jump I launched and actually if you
look in the description below I will put
a lift you're not a member of audible
yeah if you're not a member of audible
and you sign up for audible and my book
is the first one that you buy then I get
what they call a bounty
yeah big bonus like fifty bucks uh used
to be 50 now it's 75 75 let you hang on
but you have to buy it from the
particular link so I'm going to put the
link in the description below so if
you're not at audible if you're already
an audible member and you want to buy it
or like I said if you're actually a
patron if I get
free codes I'll send you a code if you
want one and becoming an audible member
is kind of like subscribing to is Stubbs
a list for AMC or like shudder or
whatever you pay a certain amount of
month of thinking you get a certain
amount of books don't you think we're
not I think just an audio books my
attention wanders yeah I think you can
spend a certain amount a month and get a
certain amount of audiobooks a month so
let's say you're a truck driver or you
do a lot of commuting and you you know
want a lot of audio material I mean a
good audio book is 12 hours 17 hours
cinema so that's that's a lot of
listening material yeah you want to
listen to my beautiful voice yeah 17 17
hours so there's all kinds of cool [ __ ]
on on audible yeah but I'll put the link
in the to the bounty or if you just want
to go to the regular thing you can go to
Amazon or audible.com and just search
you know faceless fill in volume 2 or
search my name or whatever and it comes
right up on there and like I said if you
liked it please leave a review even it
doesn't have to be long just a sentence
or something like that it really does
help a lot and I think that'll do it for
episode 124 the first episode of 2019
hopefully this will be a bigger better
year than the last one we're really
trying to make this a really good show
for you guys yeah so we will see you
next time bye
you